Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, add free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to the rest is history.com and join the club. That is the rest is history.com. This episode is brought to you by Hive. You know, history is full of transformations. The Romans shifted from Republic to Empire. the Tudor's transformed monasteries into country houses. And do you know what? Hive has had one of its own. Everybody knows Hive for smart thermostats, but now they've evolved into something much greater. Solar panels that help you to power your home with clean energy. Heat pumps that pull warmth from thin air.
感谢收听《历史的余味》（The Rest is History）。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。本期节目由 Hive 赞助。你知道，历史充满了变革。罗马人从共和国转变为帝国，都铎王朝将修道院改造成了乡村别墅。你知道吗？Hive 也经历了自己的变革。大家都知道 Hive 的智能恒温器，但现在他们已经进化成了更伟大的存在。能帮你用清洁能源为家庭供电的太阳能电池板，以及能从稀薄空气中汲取热量的热泵。
EV charges that charge your car while you're asleep. All managed through a single app. This is all about giving people the power to transform their homes, from waste to efficiency, from dependence to control, from consumption to contribution. So history's next great transformation may not be happening in parliaments or palaces. It may be happening in your home. A quiet revolution minus guillotine's. Hive. Know your power. Visit hivehome.com to find out more. Subject to survey and suitability. Hive app compatible with selected heat pumps. 20th Century Studios presents Springsteen, deliver me from nowhere. One time, baby we were born. Witness a true story of risking it all.
还有在你睡觉时为汽车充电的电动汽车充电桩。所有这些都通过一个应用程序进行管理。这一切都是为了赋予人们改造家庭的能力，从浪费到高效，从依赖到掌控，从消费到贡献。所以，历史上下一个伟大的变革可能不会发生在议会或宫殿里，它可能就发生在你的家里。一场没有断头台的静默革命。Hive。了解你的力量。访问 hivehome.com 了解更多信息。需视勘测和适用性而定。Hive 应用程序兼容部分热泵。二十世纪影业呈现《斯普林斯汀：拯救我于虚无》（Springsteen, Deliver Me From Nowhere）。曾经，宝贝，我们生而如此。见证一个孤注一掷的真实故事。
These new songs, they're the only thing making sense to me right now. To fight for what you believe in. This is not going to be good for Bruce. Don't need to be perfect. I just know it to feel right. Springsteen, deliver me from nowhere. Only in theaters Friday. Nelson gazed out at the spires of the Danish capital.
这些新歌，它们是我现在唯一能理解的东西。为了你所信仰的事物而战。这对布鲁斯来说不会是件好事。不需要完美。我只知道它感觉是对的。《斯普林斯汀：拯救我于虚无》。周五仅在影院上映。纳尔逊凝视着丹麦首都的尖塔。
With luck, he thought, the enemy would soon come to turns, and he could leave the city unscathed. That night, he invited his captains aboard the elephant for a final. dinner. He was in the highest spirits, one remembered, and drank to the success of the ensuing day. As they left, Nelson shook each man by the hand and wished him luck. When they had gone, he lay sleepless in his cot, listening to the creek of the timbers. Everything he thought, depended on a fair wind to push them into the enemy's harbour. Dawn came. Thursday, the 2nd of April, 1801, another grey, dreary day. But as Nelson stepped onto the quarter-deck, a smile spread across his face. The wind had changed, and was blowing from the southeast. The conditions could not have
他心想，如果运气好的话，敌人很快就会屈服，他就能安然无恙地离开这座城市。那天晚上，他邀请他的船长们登上“大象号”共进最后的晚餐。据一位回忆者说，他当时兴致极高，并为次日的成功干杯。他们离开时，纳尔逊与每个人握手并祝他们好运。他们走后，他躺在行军床上辗转反侧，听着木梁的吱呀声。他心想，一切都取决于是否有顺风将他们推入敌人的港口。黎明到来。1801年4月2日，星期四，又是一个阴沉灰暗的日子。但当纳尔逊踏上后甲板时，脸上露出了笑容。风向变了，正从东南方吹来。条件再好不过了。
been better. His personal troubles were forgotten. This was his world, the swell of the sea, the burden of command the thrill of battle god was with them he thought and ordered his crew to hoist signal fourteen prepare for battle a thrilling and thoroughly patriotic scene from what else adventures in time Nelson hero of the seas by top Nelson scholar Dominic Sambrook out last week I think in paperback, so a splendid read. And, I mean, the drama of it, we're in the spring of 1801 and Britain is facing a potentially mortal threat to her very survival as an independent power. So there is a huge strategic crisis that has hoved into view. Britain, if she needs to have any hope of maintaining her independence against France, needs to control the seas. But the problem is that a new czar,
他的个人烦恼被抛诸脑后。这是他的世界，海浪的起伏，指挥的重担，战斗的刺激。他心想，上帝与他们同在，于是命令船员升起第14号信号旗：准备战斗。这是来自《时间冒险：海之英雄纳尔逊》（Adventures in Time: Nelson, Hero of the Seas）中一个惊心动魄且极具爱国情怀的场景，作者是顶级纳尔逊学者多米尼克·桑布鲁克（Dominic Sambrook），我想上周刚出平装本，真是一本精彩的读物。而且，我是说，那种戏剧性，我们正处于1801年的春天，英国正面临着作为独立大国生存的潜在致命威胁。所以，一个巨大的战略危机已经显现。英国如果想保持对法国的独立，就必须控制海洋。但问题是，一位新沙皇，
Paul I, hates a waistcoat, loves issuing intemperate orders to his servants. He has organized a new league of armed neutrality, which actually isn't neutral at all, because it's directly targeted at the monopoly of supplies that Britain needs to maintain the Royal Navy. And this would then facilitate the growth of the French Navy, thereby threatening Britain's command of the seas. So, Dominic, what is Britain to do? When you're faced with a national emergency, who do you send for? Well, they send for Nelson because, as you've described, the countries of the Baltic have let themselves down by forming this League of Arm neutrality, especially, I have to say the Danes. I know, who are almost like Englishmen, according to Nelson.
保罗一世，讨厌穿背心，喜欢向仆人下达不理智的命令。他组织了一个新的武装中立联盟，但这实际上根本不中立，因为它直接针对英国维持皇家海军所需的物资垄断。这将促进法国海军的发展，从而威胁到英国对海洋的控制。那么，多米尼克，英国该怎么办？当你面临国家紧急状态时，你会派谁去？好吧，他们派了纳尔逊，因为正如你所描述的，波罗的海国家通过组建这个武装中立联盟让自己陷入了困境，我必须说，尤其是丹麦人。我知道，据纳尔逊说，他们几乎就像英国人一样。
And you don't get higher praise than that, do you? Right. There are a slightly worse version of Englishmen. And for them to rank themselves alongside the Russians, and as you say, implicitly, the French, because this will be a gift to Napoleon Bonaparte. I mean, that's the real shocker, isn't it? It is, exactly. So the Admiralty's reaction has been to send this squadron east to break this league by force, and first in line is the Danish fleet and the dockyards at Copenhagen. And listeners who remember our last episode will recall that the command of the fleet is not Nelson, it is the elderly Admiral Syed Parker, who has somehow managed to tear himself away from the delights of his teenage bride. This is the paradox, isn't it? That the reason
你得不到比这更高的评价了，对吧？没错。他们是稍微差一点的英国人。让他们把自己和俄国人，以及正如你所说的，隐含地和法国人排在一起，因为这将是送给拿破仑·波拿巴的一份大礼。我是说，那才是真正令人震惊的地方，不是吗？确实，正是如此。所以海军部的反应是派遣这支中队向东，以武力打破这个联盟，首当其冲的就是丹麦舰队和哥本哈根的造船厂。记得我们上一集的听众会记得，舰队的指挥官不是纳尔逊，而是年迈的海德·帕克海军上将，他不知何故设法从他那十几岁新娘的温柔乡中抽身出来。这就是悖论，不是吗？纳尔逊之所以
perhaps why Nelson hasn't been given command is because there's a slight shadow over his reputation as a consequence of his affair with Emma Hamilton. But So Hyde Parker isn't a model of propriety at all. It takes all sorts. I don't want to pronounce on the nature of his relationship with this young woman. As you rightly say, there is this shadow hanging over Horatio Nelson, which is the fact that he has abandoned his wife Fanny for Emma Hamilton. And I see that you've added the words, Luscious in the notes, Tom. You in your notes have described Emma as vile.
没有被授予指挥权，也许是因为他与艾玛·汉密尔顿的绯闻给他的名声蒙上了一层阴影。但海德·帕克根本不是什么正派的典范。什么人都有。我不想对他们与这个年轻女人的关系性质发表评论。正如你正确指出的，霍雷肖·纳尔逊身上确实笼罩着阴影，那就是他为了艾玛·汉密尔顿抛弃了他的妻子范妮。我看到你在笔记里加了“诱人”这个词，汤姆。你在笔记里把艾玛描述为“卑劣”。
I've crossed that out. I mean, I think it's an accurate description of her. Listeners can make up their own minds, of course. We pride ourselves, don't we, that we have these little disagreements, unlike some Gollhanger podcasts, which boast of disagreeing agreeably, but never disagree about anything. That's not the case on the rest of history. No.
我把它划掉了。我是说，我认为这是一个准确的描述。当然，听众可以自己做决定。我们引以为豪的是，我们有这些小分歧，不像某些 Gollhanger 播客，吹嘘着“愉快地分歧”，但从不就任何事情产生分歧。在《历史的余味》中情况并非如此。不。
We disagree about top mistresses and other such vital. topics. We do, exactly. So we ended last time with intelligence reaching the fleet, that Copenhagen's defences are even more formidable than Parker and Nelson expected. Huge citadel batteries, two massive forts, bristling with guns, and the Danes have created this defensive line, this kind of wall of guns made up of warships and hulks and sort of floating gun platforms are facing the sea.
我们对顶级情妇和其他此类重要话题有分歧。我们确实如此，正是。所以我们上次结束时，情报传到了舰队，哥本哈根的防御比帕克和纳尔逊预期的还要强大。巨大的城堡炮台，两座巨大的堡垒，枪炮林立，丹麦人建立了这条防御线，这种由军舰、废船和某种浮动炮台组成的枪炮之墙正对着大海。
And there's one particular fortress, isn't there? There's kind of outside, which is built on solid rock, so that's also got to be negotiated. Exactly, yeah. And of course, the water was very shallow. As always in naval battles, there's lots of action with shoals, so they have to get around this. Flat bottoms. Exactly, the shoal. So Nelson has urged Admiral Parker to launch the attack anyway. Never did our country depends so much on the success of any fleet as on this. And we ended with Parker's answer, which is, sure, all right, but you will lead the attack personally. Now, some people would find that daunting. Of course, Nelson is not a man to be daunted. He's excited. He's thrilled. On the 27th of
而且有一座特别的堡垒，不是吗？它就在外面，建在坚硬的岩石上，所以这也必须解决。没错，是的。当然，水非常浅。正如在海战中一样，浅滩有很多动作，所以他们必须绕过这个。平底船。没错，浅滩。所以纳尔逊敦促帕克海军上将无论如何都要发动进攻。我们的国家从未如此依赖任何舰队的成功。我们以帕克的回答结束，那就是，当然，没问题，但你必须亲自指挥进攻。现在，有些人会觉得这很令人生畏。当然，纳尔逊不是一个会被吓倒的人。他很兴奋。他很激动。3月27日，
March, he moves his flag from the St. George, which is the ship he'd been given back in England, to the 74-gun ship Elephant. The elephant, as Andrew Lambert points out, ironically, the badge of the Danish monarchy. And the reason he's moving, isn't it, is that the elephant has what naval people call a shallower draft. Yeah, talk us through the shallower draft. Well, it means it's better able to cope with the shallows because Dominic, it draws less water. Oh, does it? Yeah, it does. Basically, it can go in shallower water than the St. George can.
他将他的旗帜从“圣乔治号”（他在英国时被分配的船）移到了74门炮的“大象号”上。正如安德鲁·兰伯特指出的，讽刺的是，“大象号”是丹麦君主制的徽章。他搬迁的原因是，“大象号”有海军所说的“较浅的吃水”。是的，给我们讲讲较浅的吃水。好吧，这意味着它更能应付浅滩，因为多米尼克，它的吃水更浅。哦，是吗？是的，确实。基本上，它能进入比“圣乔治号”更浅的水域。
So that's why he moves. And, of course, when he moves, he makes sure to take with him his two most prized possessions, which are portraits of Emma, his guardian angels, he calls them. So they go into his new cabin. So that's splendid. That's very moving. So from the elephant, he will command this squadron of six other 74, so the 74 gunship is the sort of classic warship of the Royal Navy.
所以这就是他搬迁的原因。当然，当他搬迁时，他确保带上了他最珍视的两件财物，那就是艾玛的肖像，他称她们为他的守护天使。所以她们进了他的新船舱。所以这很棒。这非常感人。所以从“大象号”上，他将指挥这支由其他六艘74门炮战舰组成的中队，所以74门炮的战舰是皇家海军的经典战舰。
So you've got the defiance, the Ganges, the Edgar, the Belona, the Russell and the Monarch. And there are three, 64 gunships, and there are various frigates and fire ships. And crucially, there are seven bomb vessels. And these are ships that will start shelling the Danish dockyards once Nelson's warships have cleared out the defences. And Dominic, just a couple of things to say about that. Firstly, the Edgar, one of the ships, named after Athelstan's nephew. And Athelstan, of course, defeated the Danes. So maybe there's a slight kind of portent there.
所以你有“反抗号”、“恒河号”、“埃德加号”、“贝罗纳号”、“罗素号”和“君主号”。还有三艘64门炮的战舰，以及各种护卫舰和火船。至关重要的是，有七艘炸弹船。这些船将在纳尔逊的战舰清除防御后开始炮击丹麦造船厂。多米尼克，关于这一点有几件事要说。首先，“埃德加号”，其中一艘船，以埃塞尔斯坦的侄子命名。当然，埃塞尔斯坦击败了丹麦人。所以也许这有一点预兆。
And the other thing is the identity of one of Nelson's captains, who is in command of a 56er. So not quite as many guns, but still very, very formidable as we'll see. This is a ship called the HMS Glatton. And the commander of that is Captain Bly, who 12 years before had been. in command of a ship called the bounty in the Pacific Ocean that had witnessed a famous mutiny. So, Bly has lots to prove. And fortunately, the Glatton is a kind of ship that would enable him to prove things because it's armed with this new kind of cannon, the carronade, which is very short range. So if you can get the ship up close, it will flicked incredible
另一件事是纳尔逊的一位船长的身份，他指挥着一艘56门炮的船。所以炮火没那么多，但正如我们将看到的，仍然非常非常强大。这是一艘名为“HMS 格拉顿号”的船。指挥官是布莱船长，12年前他曾指挥过一艘名为“邦蒂号”的船，在太平洋上见证了一场著名的叛变。所以，布莱有很多东西要证明。幸运的是，“格拉顿号”是一种能让他证明自己的船，因为它装备了一种新型大炮，卡隆炮，射程非常短。所以如果你能让船靠近，它会造成难以置信的
damage on its target. Massive guns, and they are mounted on pivot so they can swivel round and they sweep at a range of targets. And as we will see, this makes the Glatton a very, very formidable addition to Nelson's armoury. Right. But getting into the harbour is going to be a tough job. They're waiting for the wind to sweep them in. And they haven't even got up to Copenhagen yet.
伤害。巨大的火炮，它们安装在枢轴上，所以它们可以旋转，横扫一系列目标。正如我们将看到的，这使得“格拉顿号”成为纳尔逊军火库中非常非常强大的补充。没错。但进入港口将是一项艰巨的工作。他们正在等待风把他们吹进去。而且他们甚至还没到哥本哈根。
So on the 30th of March, the wind finally shifts because they've been waiting for three days. And they sail south into the Urusund, which is the straight between Denmark and Sweden. What is it? It's called the Urusund. I'm master of tongues. I'm just guessing.
所以3月30日，风终于变了，因为他们已经等了三天。他们向南航行进入厄勒海峡，也就是丹麦和瑞典之间的海峡。它叫什么？它叫厄勒海峡。我是语言大师。我只是在猜。
I saw an O with an accent, and I thought I'd mix it up a bit. Anyway, they sail into this strait, and ahead is this great fortress of Kronborg, which is the castle of Elsinor, as in Hamlet. And they're worried that there are great guns at the castle, so they go over to the Swedish side of the strait. Although, Dominant, there's a risk there as well, isn't there? Because Sweden also is part of this league. They don't know how many guns might be there. and whether the Swedes would fire them. The Swedes are not cut from the same cloth that they were in the Great Northern War, I think, by this point.
我看到了一个带重音的O，我想我把它弄混了。总之，他们航行进入这个海峡，前面是克隆堡大堡垒，也就是哈姆雷特里的埃尔西诺城堡。他们担心城堡里有大炮，所以他们去了海峡的瑞典一侧。虽然，多米尼克，那里也有风险，不是吗？因为瑞典也是这个联盟的一部分。他们不知道那里可能有多少大炮，以及瑞典人是否会开火。我想，到这个时候，瑞典人已经不像大北方战争时期那样了。
They've already started to move in a Greta-Tunberg-style direction. Yeah. Because they don't fire. And actually, it turns out they don't really have any guns there anyway. So Nelson's gamble pays off. Exactly. So the Danish guns can't reach the British ships. The British do fire on Elsinor, don't they?
他们已经开始向格蕾塔·通贝里风格的方向发展了。是的。因为他们没有开火。而且实际上，事实证明他们那里根本没有什么大炮。所以纳尔逊的赌博成功了。没错。所以丹麦的大炮够不到英国的船只。英国人确实向埃尔西诺开火了，不是吗？
Because isn't there a cannon ball stuck in the cathedral roof or something? Yeah, apparently. So on they go into the strait, in the distance. 20 miles away as their target, the city of Copenhagen. Now, for a couple of days, they remain at anchor. It's really, really cold. The weather is terrible. And Nelson sends this little scouting parties into what is called the Outer Deep,
因为大教堂屋顶上是不是卡着一颗炮弹什么的？是的，显然。所以他们继续进入海峡，在远处。20英里外是他们的目标，哥本哈根市。现在，他们锚泊了几天。天气非常非常冷。天气很糟糕。纳尔逊派出了这些小侦察队进入所谓的“外深水区”，
which is the sea beyond just outside Copenhagen. It's all very icy, so it's kind of floating ice, and they're kind of cutting their way through. And their job is to check out the Danish defences. They have to do it at night, don't they? Yeah, it's very Hollywood, this. So kind of muffled oars, They can only use candles to inspect their charts and things.
也就是哥本哈根外面的海域。到处都是冰，所以是某种浮冰，他们正在切开一条路。他们的工作是检查丹麦的防御。他们必须在晚上做，不是吗？是的，这非常像好莱坞。所以某种消音的桨，他们只能用蜡烛来检查他们的海图之类的东西。
The amazing thing is that obviously this is the kind of adventure that Nelson is gagging to join in. And so he himself, even though he's the commander, goes out and joins these routines as well. Very dramatic scene. Yeah, he loves all this. And if you remember from last time, he has been going through agonies in his cabin, writing these letters to Emma about his paranoia, that she's going to run off with the future Prince Regent, the future George the 4th. But this is the one time where you feel like a lot of these cares slip away because this is really what he loves doing. He just loves throwing himself into this kind of adventuring. And also hanging out with his band of brothers.
令人惊奇的是，这显然是纳尔逊渴望参与的那种冒险。所以他自己，尽管他是指挥官，也出去参加了这些例行公事。非常戏剧性的场景。是的，他喜欢这一切。如果你还记得上次，他在船舱里经历了痛苦，给艾玛写信，表达他的偏执，担心她会和未来的摄政王，未来的乔治四世私奔。但这是唯一一次你觉得这些烦恼消散了，因为这确实是他喜欢做的事情。他只是喜欢把自己投入到这种冒险中。而且还和他的兄弟连在一起。
Yeah, and there's still a band of brothers element to this. So on the night of the 31st, after dinner, he has a council of war aboard the elephant. And a lot of the captains who are coming with him on this expedition are people that he served alongside at the Battle of the Nile. So names like Thomas Foley, Thomas Fremantle, George Murray. The most famous of them is Thomas Masterman Hardy, who actually volunteers to leave his own ship and come over to the elephant because he's so keen to be in on the action. And in the last couple of episodes, we talked a lot about the downsides of working with Horatio Nelson. But this is a reminder of just how inspirational, how stirring a figure he is, that there are people who want to put themselves in harm's way just to be at his side in the thick of the action. What's the Nelson touch, isn't it?
是的，这里仍然有兄弟连的元素。所以31日晚上，晚餐后，他在“大象号”上召开了军事会议。和他一起参加这次远征的许多船长都是他在尼罗河战役中并肩作战的人。所以像托马斯·福利、托马斯·弗里曼特尔、乔治·默里这样的名字。其中最著名的是托马斯·马斯特曼·哈迪，他实际上自愿离开自己的船来到“大象号”，因为他非常渴望参与行动。在过去几集中，我们谈了很多与霍雷肖·纳尔逊共事的缺点。但这提醒了我们，他是多么鼓舞人心、多么令人振奋的人物，以至于有人愿意让自己身处险境，只为在他身边处于行动的核心。这就是“纳尔逊之触”，不是吗？
the sense that huge drama is going to happen and it's probably going to work out well. Yeah, and he is a man who's brilliant at bringing people into his confidence and inspiring them. There are these sort of descriptions of him, this guy called Colonel Stuart, William Stewart, who's commanding the sort of ground troops they've brought with them. And Stuart describes Nelson afterwards as pacing up and down, shaking his head at any sign of alarm or irresolution, burning with excitement and energy as he describes his plan. This is a preview of what he will do at Trafalgar, of course, sharing his plan with his captains.
那种巨大的戏剧性即将发生，而且很可能会顺利解决的感觉。是的，他是一个擅长赢得人们信任并激励他们的人。有一些关于他的描述，这个叫斯图尔特上校，威廉·斯图尔特的人，他指挥着他们带来的某种地面部队。斯图尔特后来描述纳尔逊在甲板上踱步，对任何警报或犹豫的迹象摇头，当他描述他的计划时，他燃烧着兴奋和能量。这当然是他在特拉法尔加所做之事的预演，与他的船长们分享他的计划。
Yeah, and he's brilliant at generating this kind of sense of a shared bond. I mean, almost a kind of a manly love that animates everybody in command under Nelson to feel that they're part of a shared enterprise, and that that enterprise is going to be something bold, something dramatic, and ultimately something successful that you simply wouldn't get with any other admiral and a glaring contrast with Sir Hyde Parker
是的，他非常擅长产生这种共享纽带的感觉。我是说，几乎是一种激励纳尔逊指挥下的每个人都感到他们是共享事业的一部分的男人之爱，而且那种事业将是某种大胆、某种戏剧性、最终某种成功的事情，你根本无法从任何其他海军上将那里得到，这与海德·帕克形成了鲜明的对比，
who's not part of this. I mean, he's kind of stuck in the rear. He's absolutely not the kind of person who could marshal this kind of project. No, exactly. And in fact, he's quite nervous about it. Well, he's nervous because it's a very risky plan. Basically, what they're going to do
他不是其中的一部分。我是说，他有点被困在后方。他绝对不是那种能组织这种项目的人。不，确实。事实上，他对此非常紧张。好吧，他紧张是因为这是一个风险很大的计划。基本上，他们要做的是
is they're going to sail into Copenhagen harbour from the southeast. And to do that, they'll have to loop around this central sort of shoal or sandbank known as the middle ground and if they loop around that and come up from the south that will bring them into what's called the Kings Deep which is this quite narrow channel
他们将从东南方航行进入哥本哈根港。为了做到这一点，他们必须绕过这个被称为“中间地带”的中央浅滩或沙洲，如果他们绕过那个并从南面上来，那将把他们带入所谓的“国王深水区”，这是一个相当狭窄的通道，
between the shoal and the city but is as its name suggests deep because I suppose the risk is that I mean it's exactly the risk that Nelson faced at the Battle of the Nile where similarly there were kind of shoals and islands and sandbanks and so on and listeners may remember that one of the most celebrated of all Nelson's captains, Thomas Trowbridge, ends up stranded there
在浅滩和城市之间，但正如其名，很深，因为我想风险在于，我是说，这正是纳尔逊在尼罗河战役中面临的风险，那里同样有某种浅滩、岛屿和沙洲等等，听众可能记得，纳尔逊最著名的船长之一，托马斯·特罗布里奇，最终在那里搁浅了，
and he's terribly upset about this and Nelson has to push for him to get a medal, even though he hadn't taken part in the fight. That's right. And there is absolutely a risk because actually that the channel here, the deep, is even narrower than it had been in Egypt, that people will get stranded similarly. However, Nelson has made this less likely by having the shoals marked out with boys, because normally there would be boys there, but the Danes have removed the boys to make it more challenging for the British. And he has a splendid man, splendid officer who he entrusts with this task. And this is a guy called Captain Edward Ryu, who's very junior officer, but has had an amazing career. So he'd been a midshipman on Cook's third and final
他对此感到非常难过，纳尔逊不得不推动他获得一枚奖章，尽管他没有参加战斗。没错。而且绝对有风险，因为实际上这里的通道，深水区，比埃及的还要窄，人们会同样搁浅。然而，纳尔逊通过用浮标标出浅滩，使这种情况发生的可能性降低了，因为通常那里会有浮标，但丹麦人移除了浮标，使英国人更具挑战性。他有一位出色的人，出色的军官，他委托他完成这项任务。这是一个叫爱德华·里乌船长的人，他是非常初级的军官，但有着惊人的职业生涯。所以他曾是库克第三次也是最后一次航行的见习官，
voyage, the voyage in which Captain Cook ends up being killed in Hawaii. Yeah. There'd been massive drama with a convict ship that he'd been in command of. He was taking prisoners to Botany Bay, and they had tried to get water from an iceberg, and the iceberg had sliced a hole in the bottom of the ship. Wow. And they kept trying to bail the water out. And some of the crew say, oh, this is hopeless, we're getting out of here, and they go off in ships. But Ryu stays on board, and he uses the convicts as a crew. So it's almost the opposite of Bly. Bly had lost his crew. Ryu recruits convicts to serve him as his crew. And somehow they managed to survive and they get rescued. I don't know if you've read Desolation Island. Of course, Patrick O'Brien.
那次航行中库克船长最终在夏威夷被杀。是的。他指挥的一艘囚犯船发生了巨大的戏剧性事件。他正带着囚犯去植物学湾，他们试图从冰山上取水，冰山在船底切开了一个洞。哇。他们一直试图把水舀出来。一些船员说，哦，这没希望了，我们离开这里，他们乘船走了。但里乌留在船上，他用囚犯作为船员。所以这几乎和布莱相反。布莱失去了他的船员。里乌招募囚犯作为他的船员。不知何故，他们设法生存下来并获救。我不知道你有没有读过《荒凉岛》。当然，帕特里克·奥布莱恩。
So this is exactly the plot of that. It's a direct inspiration for it. Yeah, it's an amazing scene in Patrick O'Brien. Yeah. And so there's something of Jack Aubrey, Patrick O'Brien's hero, about Captain Ryu. And you can see exactly why that would appeal to Nelson. And so he has given Ryu not command of a kind of major ship of the line. but of a small squadron of frigates. And he gives him a kind of roving commission in the battle to come. You know, if the kind of happenstance intervenes, if things go wrong, Riu is to rely on his initiative and basically behave as Nelson likes to behave in battles.
所以这正是那个情节。它是它的直接灵感来源。是的，帕特里克·奥布莱恩书中的一个惊人场景。是的。所以里乌船长身上有杰克·奥布里（帕特里克·奥布莱恩的英雄）的影子。你可以看出为什么这会吸引纳尔逊。所以他没有给里乌指挥一艘主力舰，而是指挥了一支小型护卫舰中队。他在即将到来的战斗中给了他某种巡逻任务。你知道，如果某种偶然情况介入，如果事情出错，里乌要依靠他的主动性，基本上表现得像纳尔逊在战斗中喜欢表现的那样。
Yeah. So that's how they're getting round the sandbanks or the shoals. But once they've done that, they're then into the harbour and there's this line of Danish ships. Now here they really have to take a gamble. Each of Nelson's ships is given a different target. and they kind of move up the line towards their targets one by one, and they keep going until they've cleared them all out of the way. And Nelson says, when you do this, the Danes will be absolutely,
是的。所以这就是他们绕过沙洲或浅滩的方法。但一旦他们做到了，他们就进入了港口，那里有一排丹麦船只。现在在这里他们真的必须赌一把。纳尔逊的每艘船都被分配了一个不同的目标，他们一个接一个地向他们的目标移动，他们一直前进，直到他们把它们全部清除。纳尔逊说，当你这样做时，丹麦人将绝对，
there will be a blizzard of Danish fire. But we should get, quote, so close to our enemies that every shot cannot miss. Let's give them that hailstorm of bullets, which gives our dear country, the dominion of the seas. That's very Nelson. And that's why the carinades are so useful in such a fight. Yeah. Plus, getting up really close. So you advance closer and closer in the face of their withering fire and then you just unload and unleash hell on them. So you've got to be pretty brave. All right, we come to the morning of the 1st of April. The wind has begun to shift in their favor. Nelson calls the masters and the pilots of the ships for a last briefing on the elephant. Then he himself gets into a little rowing boat and he goes to visit as many ships as he can. And there's a midshipman who remembers, he says, I always remember Nelson, his squeaking little voice and his Norfolk draw. Alan Partridge. Alan Partridge, exactly.
将会有丹麦人的炮火暴风雪。但我们应该，引用，“如此接近我们的敌人，以至于每一发炮弹都不能落空。”让我们给他们那场弹雨，这给了我们亲爱的国家，海洋的统治权。这非常纳尔逊。这就是为什么卡隆炮在这样的战斗中如此有用。是的。加上，靠得非常近。所以你在他们枯萎的炮火面前越来越近，然后你只是卸下并释放地狱。所以你必须非常勇敢。好吧，我们来到4月1日早上。风已经开始向有利于他们的方向转变。纳尔逊召集船上的船长和领航员在“大象号”上进行最后一次简报。然后他自己坐上一艘小划艇，去拜访他能拜访的尽可能多的船只。有一位见习官记得，他说，我总是记得纳尔逊，他尖细的小嗓音和他的诺福克口音。艾伦·帕特里奇。艾伦·帕特里奇，没错。
Very good. So they start to move south that afternoon. When they see the signal to begin the operation, great cheers rise from the cruise. And in the distance, of course, they can now see the spires of Copenhagen. And they can also make out the outline of the defensive line across the harbour, this wall of guns.
非常好。所以那天下午他们开始向南移动。当他们看到开始行动的信号时，船员们爆发出巨大的欢呼声。在远处，当然，他们现在可以看到哥本哈根的尖塔。他们还可以辨认出港口对面的防御线轮廓，这道枪炮之墙。
And as dusk is falling, we have that scene that you opened with Tom. I described in such purple prose. Sturing prose, Dominic. Thanks, Tom. Honestly, I read it and I felt a thrill. Well, there is no higher recommendation than that, and parents listening to this podcast should immediately run out and buy this book for their children.
当黄昏降临时，我们有了你开场时描述的那个场景，汤姆。我用如此华丽的散文描述的。令人振奋的散文，多米尼克。谢谢，汤姆。老实说，我读了它，我感到一阵激动。好吧，没有比这更高的推荐了，听这个播客的父母应该立即跑出去为他们的孩子买这本书。
I mean, you have already, but just buy more copies. Christmas is coming. Exactly. So there's dinner, they drink a toast to victory, and then Nelson, of course, stays up late, doesn't he? And he has Ryu with him. With Ryu, right. And what are they doing?
我是说，你已经买了，但多买几本。圣诞节快到了。没错。所以有晚餐，他们为胜利干杯，然后纳尔逊当然熬夜了，不是吗？他有里乌和他在一起。和里乌在一起，没错。他们在做什么？
Well, they're drawing up very, very detailed plans. So this is not really a battle where Nelson wants captains to show initiative. I mean, if they have to, then they do. but if they can possibly avoid it, then they're given very precise instructions. So, for instance, about which of the enemy ships to target. And they draw these up, and Ryu helps him, and then these orders are sent out to all the various ships, so that every captain knows what is expected of him. Well, a lot of them have pieces of paper.
好吧，他们正在制定非常非常详细的计划。所以这不是一场纳尔逊希望船长们表现出主动性的战斗。我是说，如果他们必须，那他们就做。但如果他们能尽可能避免，那他们就会得到非常精确的指示。所以，例如，关于瞄准哪艘敌舰。他们制定了这些，里乌帮助他，然后这些命令被发送到所有不同的船只，以便每个船长都知道对他有什么期望。好吧，他们中的许多人有纸片。
They actually hold pieces of paper, almost out index cards telling them what to do. Now, that night, not surprisingly, Nelson finds it very hard to sleep. He's constantly calling for news of the wind. He needs the wind to be able to speed them into the harbour. When he wakes, he gets the news that he wanted, the wind is with them. So, six o'clock, Nelson's up, he's dressed, he has had his breakfast, he has his plans written out on these cards. They're little cards that he can hold in one hand.
他们实际上拿着纸片，几乎是索引卡，告诉他们该做什么。现在，那天晚上，不出所料，纳尔逊发现很难入睡。他不断要求风的消息。他需要风来加速他们进入港口。当他醒来时，他得到了他想要的消息，风与他们同在。所以，六点钟，纳尔逊起床了，他穿好衣服，他吃了早餐，他有写在这些卡片上的计划。它们是他可以单手拿住的小卡片。
Why? Because he doesn't have two hands, of course. Because he'd lost his arm. At eight o'clock, as we heard in the introduction, he hoist Signal 14, prepare for battle. And then at about 9.45, another signal goes up. he tells the first four ships. They are the Edgar, which you described, the ardent, the glatton.
为什么？因为他没有两只手，当然。因为他失去了手臂。在八点钟，正如我们在介绍中听到的，他升起了第14号信号旗，准备战斗。然后在9点45分左右，另一个信号升起。他告诉前四艘船。它们是“埃德加号”（你描述的那艘）、“火热号”、“格拉顿号”。
So that's under Bly. That's Bly, and the ISIS to weigh anchor and to advance around the shoals into the king's deep. And then 10 minutes later, the next lot of ships, the Agamemnon, the Balona, the Ganges, the monarch, the defiance, the Russell, and the Polyphemus. And it's excruciating moment, I guess, for Nelson. them because now the huge anxieties are any of his ships going to be stranded?
所以那是在布莱指挥下。那是布莱，还有“伊希斯号”起锚并绕过浅滩进入国王深水区。然后10分钟后，下一批船，“阿伽门农号”、“贝罗纳号”、“恒河号”、“君主号”、“反抗号”、“罗素号”和“波吕斐摩斯号”。我想这对纳尔逊来说是极其痛苦的时刻。因为现在巨大的焦虑是他的船只中是否有任何一艘会搁浅？
And yet what a thrill he must have felt at seeing the execution of his battle plan. Oh, yeah. So nervousness and excitement kind of intermingle. I think the only reason that Hollywood hasn't made films of these kinds of things is just so complicated and expensive because it's such a cinematic scene. The British ships, most of them have painted their holes dark, yellow and black. So the Wolverhampton Wanderers colours, Tom. And the colours that visitors to Wait a Miss victory at Portsmouth will have seen.
然而，看到他的战斗计划的执行，他一定感到多么激动。哦，是的。所以紧张和兴奋交织在一起。我想好莱坞没有拍摄这类电影的唯一原因就是太复杂和昂贵了，因为这是一个如此电影化的场景。英国船只，它们中的大多数把船体漆成了深黄色和黑色。所以是狼队颜色，汤姆。以及参观朴茨茅斯的胜利号的游客会看到的颜色。
Exactly. So they look incredible and they move very slowly, obviously. They're kind of gliding into position. Their decks have been cleared for action. You know, what a sight they must have been. Just the spectacle of it. I always think in these naval battles, particularly under Nelson, where the point is to get up very close and inflict maximum damage.
没错。所以它们看起来令人难以置信，而且它们移动得非常缓慢，显然。它们正滑入位置。它们的甲板已经为行动清理干净了。你知道，它们一定是多么壮观。仅仅是那种景象。我总是认为在这些海战中，特别是在纳尔逊指挥下，重点是靠得非常近并造成最大伤害。
this is not what conventionally happens in battles, that the contrast between the unbelievable violence that is threatening and the slow and stately pace with which the ships glide towards their enemies must ratchet up the tension to a peculiar degree. Definitely. Yeah, there's a wonderful description by midshipman on the monarch, which was near the back of the line. And this is a guy called William Salter Millard. I'll quote him again later. He said when he saw the Ed leading the way as they'd sort of begin the turn. It was the most beautiful and solemn spectacle he'd seen in his life. A man of war under sail is at all times a beautiful object,
这不是战斗中通常发生的事情，那种威胁的难以置信的暴力与船只滑向敌人时缓慢而庄严的步伐之间的对比，一定把紧张感提升到了一个特殊的程度。绝对。是的，在“君主号”上的一位见习官有精彩的描述，它在队列的后方。这是一个叫威廉·索尔特·米拉德的人。我稍后会再引用他。他说当他看到“埃德加号”带头，当他们开始转向时。这是他一生中见过的最美丽、最庄严的景象。一艘战舰在航行中始终是一个美丽的物体，
but at such a time, the scene is heightened beyond the powers of description. We saw her pressing on through the enemy's fire, this is the Edgar. Our minds were deeply impressed with awe, and not a word was spoken throughout the ship, but by the pilot and the helmsman. Yeah, that's silence of people knowing that very soon they're going to be standing on a deck. that is going to be ravaged and raked by cannon fire and sniper shot. I mean, and what makes it even more cinematic, the sense of spectacle, is that the people of Copenhagen have come out to watch.
但在这样的时刻，场景被提升到了无法描述的地步。我们看到她冲破敌人的炮火，这就是“埃德加号”。我们的内心深受敬畏，除了领航员和舵手，船上没有说一句话。是的，那种人们知道很快他们就会站在甲板上的沉默。那将被炮火和狙击手射击蹂躏和扫射。我是说，而且是什么让它更具电影感，那种壮观的感觉，是哥本哈根的人民出来观看。
So there are thousands of people, crowds on the waterfront, people packed onto the keys, onto the balconies, onto the roofs of the houses. They're watching it as though it's a great sporting occasion or something. Well, Nelson loves an audience, doesn't he? I mean, in a way, he's a kind of great dramatist. Yes, exactly. So the Edgar leads the way around the middle ground and comes up from the south into the Kings deep.
所以有成千上万的人，滨水区的人群，挤在码头、阳台、房屋屋顶上的人。他们看着它，就好像这是一场伟大的体育赛事什么的。好吧，纳尔逊喜欢观众，不是吗？我是说，在某种程度上，他是一位伟大的剧作家。是的，正是。所以“埃德加号”带头绕过中间地带，从南面进入国王深水区。
And ahead are the Citadel Batteries, the line of 18 Danish ships moored in the harbour and the two Danish forts, and all of them are making ready to fire on the invaders. The first shots come at around 10.15. The first Danish ship, the Prouvestinen, opens fire, are the Edgar. And then one by one, the British ships move up the line and other Danish ships start firing, too.
前面是城堡炮台，港口里停泊的18艘丹麦船只和两座丹麦堡垒，它们都在准备向入侵者开火。第一批炮弹在10点15分左右射出。第一艘丹麦船，“普罗维斯蒂宁号”，向“埃德加号”开火。然后一艘接一艘，英国船只沿线移动，其他丹麦船只也开始开火。
So you have a crash of thunder and smoke pouring above the harbour and all of this kind of thing. Which is so thick that the people actually who've come out to watch can't see it. Yeah, disappointing. And for the ships themselves, I mean, you know, again, it's actually quite hard to distinguish who you're firing at. Right. And this slight sense of chaos is heightened by the fact that further back, not unpredictably, some of the British ships have started to run aground on the shoals. Yeah, and this is the big issue.
所以你有一声雷鸣，烟雾在港口上方倾泻，所有这类事情。烟雾太浓了，以至于出来观看的人实际上看不见它。是的，令人失望。对于船只本身，我是说，你知道，实际上很难分辨你在向谁开火。没错。这种轻微的混乱感被进一步加剧，因为在后方，不出所料，一些英国船只已经开始在浅滩上搁浅。是的，这是大问题。
So for all the efforts of this guy, Ryu, it's really hard for them to work out where the shoals begin and end. Three of them, in particular the Agamemnon, the Balona and the Russell have got stuck. So that means that they can still fire at the Danes, but they're kind of sitting ducks themselves. They're just sort of stuck there. And also it means that Nelson's line is now shortened because he had 12 ships of line. He's lost three. So his line is much shorter than he had planned. However, people may
所以尽管里乌这个人付出了努力，但他们真的很难弄清楚浅滩从哪里开始到哪里结束。其中三艘，特别是“阿伽门农号”、“贝罗纳号”和“罗素号”被困住了。这意味着它们仍然可以向丹麦人开火，但它们自己成了活靶子。它们只是被困在那里。而且这也意味着纳尔逊的队列现在缩短了，因为他有12艘战列舰。他损失了三艘。所以他的队列比他计划的要短得多。然而，人们可能
remember that Ryu has been given a kind of roving brief by Nelson. And so he, in an unprompted but very Nelsonian manner, comes to the rescue. He's on a ship called the Amazon. He's got four other frigates with him. So that's about, what, 150 guns between them. And they work their way up the British line, you know, dense cannon smoke drifting everywhere. And they situate themselves at the head of the line so that the loss of these three massive ships, it's not quite as bad and damaging as it might otherwise have been. And this is exactly what Nelson would have wanted Ryu to do, even though he has no direct orders, because obviously communication between Nelson's flagship and Rio is impossible. That's right. So by about half past 11, all of Nelson's
记得里乌得到了纳尔逊某种巡逻任务。所以他，以一种未经提示但非常纳尔逊的方式，前来救援。他在一艘名为“亚马逊号”的船上。他带着其他四艘护卫舰。所以它们之间大约有150门炮。它们沿着英国队列向上移动，你知道，浓密的炮烟到处飘散。它们把自己安置在队列的最前面，这样这三艘大型战舰的损失就不像本来可能的那样糟糕和具有破坏性了。这正是纳尔逊希望里乌做的，尽管他没有直接命令，因为显然纳尔逊的旗舰和里乌之间的通讯是不可能的。没错。所以到11点半左右，纳尔逊所有的
ships are engaged in one way or another. And the elephant is now flying Nelson's favorite signal, which is signal number 16, engage the enemy more closely. Now, the Danes, I know we have Danish listeners, and I definitely don't want to make this an anti-Dainish podcast. That's the last thing we would ever do. They are fighting with enormous courage. They knew from the beginning that they were really up against it, that they couldn't really compete with the Royal Navy. But they were determined to kind of fight for their capital city anyway. So they're blasting away from their ships and their gun platforms.
船只都以某种方式参与了战斗。而“大象号”现在正悬挂着纳尔逊最喜欢的信号，即第16号信号，更紧密地与敌人交战。现在，丹麦人，我知道我们有丹麦听众，我绝对不想让这成为一个反丹麦的播客。那是我们永远不会做的最后一件事。他们以巨大的勇气战斗。他们从一开始就知道他们真的处于劣势，他们无法真正与皇家海军竞争。但他们仍然决心为他们的首都而战。所以他们从他们的船只和炮台上猛烈开火。
In his book, Empire of the Deep, the historian Ben Wilson, makes what should be the obvious point, but it hadn't really occurred to me, that there is a massive difference, between this and previous battles. Previously, when Nelson fought the Spanish or the French, they'd sort of fought on, as it were, neutral territory, you know, out at sea or in Egypt or whatever. But this is very different. The Danes are defending their own capital city, their own homes, their native land,
在他的书《深海帝国》中，历史学家本·威尔逊提出了一个本应是显而易见的观点，但我并没有真正想到，那就是这与之前的战斗有巨大的区别。以前，当纳尔逊与西班牙人或法国人作战时，他们是在某种中立领土上作战，你知道，在海上或埃及或其他地方。但这非常不同。丹麦人正在保卫他们自己的首都，他们自己的家园，他们自己的国土，
in front of their friends and families, who are the people watching from the quaysides. Well, I mean, for the Danes, it's a home match, right? Yeah, exactly, exactly. And they don't get to fight many home matches, I would guess, the Danes. Historically, the Danes have preferred to fight their matches on English soil. Yes, exactly. There's an element of vengeance for Linders' farm there, perhaps.
在他们的朋友和家人面前，这些人是从码头上观看的人。好吧，我是说，对于丹麦人来说，这是主场比赛，对吧？是的，正是，正是。而且我猜丹麦人没有机会打很多主场比赛。历史上，丹麦人更喜欢在英国领土上打他们的比赛。是的，正是。那里也许有一点为林迪斯法恩复仇的成分。
Oh, that's nice. Yeah, that scar will never really heal, will it? Not really, no. So the Danes are inflicting tremendous damage. Nelson's ships are taking horrific punishment. So the Edgar, under Captain George Murray, as you said, named after Edgar the Peaceable, great law and order enthusiast. Yeah, in the 10th century.
哦，那很好。是的，那道伤疤永远不会真正愈合，不是吗？不完全是，不。所以丹麦人造成了巨大的伤害。纳尔逊的船只受到了可怕的惩罚。所以“埃德加号”，在乔治·默里船长指挥下，正如你所说，以埃德加和平者命名，伟大的法律和秩序爱好者。是的，在10世纪。
The Edgar is taking close. fossil damage. 142 men killed and wounded. The ardent loses almost 100 men and its sails and its hull are absolutely perforated by Danish shots. But worst of all, the monarch at the back of the line. This is absolutely hammered by those Danish forts. So the monarch lost 220 men killed and wounded. One of them was the captain who was a guy with James Moss who was killed on the quarter deck holding his battle plan in one hand and a speaking trumpet in the other. through which he was kind of rousing his men. And Dominic, it's not surprising that under such a firestorm,
“埃德加号”受到了近距离的化石伤害。142人伤亡。“火热号”损失了近100人，它的帆和船体被丹麦炮弹完全打穿了。但最糟糕的是，队列后方的“君主号”。这被那些丹麦堡垒完全锤击了。所以“君主号”损失了220人伤亡。其中之一是船长，一个叫詹姆斯·莫斯的人，他在后甲板上被杀，一只手拿着战斗计划，另一只手拿着扩音喇叭。通过它，他正在某种程度上激励他的船员。多米尼克，在这样的炮火下，
the captain and many other officers would be killed because those who are not officers are allowed to duck when cannonballs come in. Officers are not supposed to. You're supposed to stand there upright. And we'll be hearing accounts in this story of officers who just kind of disintegrate, get torn into. The courage required to be an officer in the Royal Navy under gunfire. I think it's just insane.
船长和许多其他军官会被杀并不奇怪，因为那些不是军官的人在炮弹飞来时被允许躲避。军官是不允许的。你应该直立站在那里。在这个故事中，我们将听到关于那些只是某种程度上解体、被撕碎的军官的描述。在炮火下作为皇家海军军官所需的勇气。我认为这简直是疯了。
Imagine, I mean, we've described it in a slightly offhand way, but just imagine sailing your ship, advancing very slowly towards a fort or a gun platform that's just sitting there blasting at you and you just say, keep going, keep going, closer, closer. Which is why, historically, this is not how battles have been fought. And what Nelson is relying on, I suppose, is two things. Firstly, the superior quality of British gunnery, which is easily the best in the world. And secondly, the martial spirit of his captains, and that's why this sense of a band of brothers, the sense of the Nelson touch, the sense of his charisma animating the battle line is so important because I think under Hyde Parker, for instance, they would not behave with such courage. But knowing that Nelson believes in them clearly gives them the courage to sustain this appalling damage and constantly run the risk of death. To walk into the jaws of death. Yeah.
想象一下，我的意思是，我们刚才用一种略显随意的口吻描述了它，但试着想象一下，你驾驶着战舰，极其缓慢地向一座正对着你狂轰滥炸的堡垒或炮台推进，而你却说，继续，继续，再近点，再近点。这就是为什么从历史上看，战斗从来不是这样进行的。我想，纳尔逊所依赖的是两点。首先，英国炮术的卓越品质，这在世界上绝对是最好的。其次，他麾下舰长们的尚武精神，这就是为什么这种“兄弟连”的感觉，这种“纳尔逊风格”的感觉，这种他那激励着整个战线的个人魅力如此重要的原因，因为我认为，如果换作海德·帕克指挥，他们绝不会表现得如此勇敢。但他们知道纳尔逊信任他们，这显然给了他们承受这种可怕伤害并不断冒着生命危险的勇气。去直面死亡的深渊。是的。
And, you know, Nelson, he is the embodiment of this, but he has to be, it's very important to him that he is the physical embodiment of the spirit. This again anticipates what we see at Trafalgar. So on the quarter-deck of the elephant, he is pacing up and down under fire, heedless of his own safety. So Colonel Stewart, the guy I quoted earlier, is at his side. Stuart went on to fight in the peninsular war with tremendous sort of courage and acclaim. But he said afterwards that he had never felt such. admiration for any officer on sea or on land, as he did for Nelson at Copenhagen. There's a point at which a Danish shot smashes into their main mast and it showers them with splinters. A splinter can kill you. And Nelson has, of course, been hit by a splinter before at the Nile. But Nelson, just oblivious to it, says to Stuart, it is warm work. And this day may be the last for any of us at any moment. But mark you, I would not be anywhere else for thousands. And that for me is the embodiment of British pluck. The other splendidly British thing that Nelson says at this point is he draws on a cricket metaphor.
而且，你知道，纳尔逊是这种精神的化身，但他必须是，对他来说，成为这种精神的肉体化身非常重要。这再次预示了我们在特拉法尔加海战中看到的情景。所以，在“象”号战舰的后甲板上，他在炮火下踱来踱去，完全不顾自己的安危。所以，我之前引用的斯图尔特上校当时就在他身边。斯图尔特后来以极大的勇气和声望参加了半岛战争。但他事后说，他从未对海陆上的任何军官像对哥本哈根战役中的纳尔逊那样感到如此钦佩。有一次，一枚丹麦炮弹击中了他们的主桅杆，碎片四溅。碎片是会要人命的。当然，纳尔逊在尼罗河海战中就曾被碎片击中过。但纳尔逊对此毫不在意，他对斯图尔特说，这真是场热火朝天的活儿。这一天对我们任何一个人来说都可能随时是最后一天。但请记住，即便给我几千英镑，我也绝不会去别的地方。对我来说，这就是英国人坚毅精神的化身。纳尔逊此时说的另一句非常英式的话是，他用了一个板球比喻。
Yeah. You know, he's anxious that perhaps this is going to take slightly longer than he thought, but still confident of victory. And he says, we shall bowl them out in four if we cannot do it in three hours. So in other words, dismiss the opposition batsman. And slowly but surely, the things you described, British teamwork, training, firepower, speed, they are beginning to tell. The Danes just, for all their efforts, they just can't compete with it. By about one o'clock, their flagship, which is called the Danabrog, 74-gun ship, is in real, real trouble. It's being powdered, isn't it, by Captain Bly's ship?
是的。你知道，他担心这可能比他预想的要稍微久一点，但仍然对胜利充满信心。他说，如果三小时内搞不定，我们四小时内一定能把他们“投杀出局”。换句话说，就是淘汰对方的击球手。慢慢地，但肯定地，你所描述的那些东西——英国式的团队合作、训练、火力、速度——开始显现威力了。丹麦人尽管竭尽全力，却根本无法与之抗衡。大约一点钟左右，他们的旗舰，那艘名为“丹内布罗格”号的74门炮战舰，陷入了真正的、巨大的麻烦。它被布莱船长的船轰得粉碎，不是吗？
Yeah, by the Gatton. And this is where the carinades are coming into their own, of course, because they are absolutely lethal at short range. And that is exactly where Bly is. I mean, he's right up close against the Danish flagship. So there's another Danish ship, the Sealand, which has lost a third of its crew. it's lost its mast, it lost its guns, it's riddled with holes. Most of its surviving crew
是的，被“加顿”号。当然，这就是短程火炮发挥作用的地方，因为它们在近距离内绝对是致命的。而布莱所处的位置正是如此。我的意思是，他紧贴着丹麦旗舰。所以还有另一艘丹麦战舰“西兰”号，它已经损失了三分之一的船员。它失去了桅杆，失去了火炮，船身布满了弹孔。它大部分幸存的船员
are desperately getting into little boats to get away. And it starts to drift, doesn't it? Yeah, because they cut the cables. It's kind of drifting across the battle line. Like a ghost ship almost. I mean, very eerie. You can imagine it kind of looming out of the gun smoke.
正拼命挤进小船逃生。它开始漂流了，对吧？是的，因为他们切断了缆绳。它就这样在战线上漂流。几乎像一艘幽灵船。我的意思是，非常诡异。你可以想象它从硝烟中隐约浮现的样子。
Nobody knows where it's going, caught on the currents. I mean, an awesome sight. And then there's a third ship, the Prouvestinen. This has been swept clear with Grapeshot, the upper decks. Its guns are disabled. Three fires are burning on this ship. 75 men are either dead or horribly wounded. It really feels at this point we're about 1 o'clock
没人知道它要去哪儿，被水流裹挟着。我的意思是，那景象令人敬畏。然后是第三艘船，“普罗维斯蒂宁”号。它的上层甲板被葡萄弹扫荡一空。它的火炮已瘫痪。船上燃起了三处大火。75人要么阵亡，要么受了重伤。在这一点上，也就是大约一点钟，感觉真的
that it is only a matter of time before the Danish line disintegrates completely and then Nelson can send in these bomb vessels to start shelling the city. And then, at about half past one, something else happens. So behind them is Admiral Hyde Parker with the reserve. He's with the rest of the British ships. And from behind them, Nelson and his officers hear the dull thud of two guns, a signal. And they turn, and they can't believe their eyes, because on the mast of Admiral Parker's flagship, they can see a new signal, which is signal number 39, discontinue the action. And what has happened? Parker has been watching this slaughter unfold, and he is calling the whole thing off. It will all be, for
丹麦防线彻底瓦解只是时间问题，然后纳尔逊就可以派这些轰炸船开始炮击城市了。然后，在大约一点半，发生了另一件事。在他们身后是带着预备队的海德·帕克海军上将。他带着其余的英国战舰。从他们身后，纳尔逊和他的军官们听到了两声沉闷的炮响，这是一个信号。他们转过身，简直不敢相信自己的眼睛，因为在帕克上将旗舰的桅杆上，他们可以看到一个新的信号，即第39号信号：停止战斗。发生了什么事？帕克一直在看着这场屠杀展开，他要叫停这一切。这一切都将是
nothing. All of their effort, all of the sacrifice or the bloodshed will have been pointless. And on the quarter-deck of the elephant, all eyes turn to Nelson. What will he do now? Wow. Well, I think we should take a break at this point. And when we come back, we have the massive excitement of describing one of the most iconic and quite possibly mythic episodes in the whole of British history. This episode is brought to you by Vanguard. Now, thrillingly, this name Vanguard was inspired by HMS Vanguard, the flagship of none other than Admiral Nelson. He pursues the French to Abacier Bay on the shores of Egypt for the Battle of the Nile.
徒劳的。他们所有的努力，所有的牺牲或流血都将毫无意义。在“象”号的后甲板上，所有的目光都转向了纳尔逊。他现在会怎么做？哇。好吧，我想我们现在应该休息一下。当我们回来时，我们将以极大的兴奋描述英国历史上最标志性、甚至可能是神话般的事件之一。本集由先锋领航（Vanguard）赞助播出。令人激动的是，这个名字“先锋”的灵感来自于“先锋”号战舰，它正是纳尔逊上将的旗舰。他追击法国人至埃及海岸的阿布基尔湾，进行了尼罗河海战。
Save the world from Napoleon, really. So great scenes. So tremendous record there from Vanguard, a ship that certainly saw no lack of action. Yes. Now, speaking of action. If you want to put your financial plans into action, but you've been putting off sorting out your ISA, or if you're new to investing and you don't know where to start, Vanguard offers a range of ISA options, including their managed ISA, which could be a great fit. So essentially, it's stocks and shares ISA, but it is managed by the experts of Vanguard. They'll help you to work out your risk appetite, match you to an investment plan that is right for you,
真的把世界从拿破仑手中拯救了出来。场面非常宏大。先锋号的战绩非常辉煌，这艘船确实从不缺乏战斗。是的。说到行动。如果你想把你的财务计划付诸行动，但一直推迟整理你的个人储蓄账户（ISA），或者如果你是投资新手，不知道从哪里开始，先锋领航提供了一系列ISA选择，包括他们的管理型ISA，这可能是一个很好的选择。本质上，它是一个股票和股份ISA，但由先锋领航的专家进行管理。他们会帮你计算你的风险承受能力，为你匹配适合你的投资计划，
and then they will do the rest. Search a fangard to find out more when investing your capital is at risk. Tax rules apply. Hi, it's Gary Linneka here and I want to tell you about a fantastic new quiz book from Gollhanger, the team behind the smash hit podcast. The rest is entertainment, the rest is history,
然后他们会完成剩下的工作。搜索“先锋领航”以了解更多信息，投资资本有风险。税收规则适用。嗨，我是加里·莱因克尔，我想向你们介绍一本来自Gollhanger的精彩新问答书，他们是热门播客《其余皆是娱乐》、《其余皆是历史》的幕后团队，
the rest is politics, the rest is classified, and of course, the rest is football. The rest is quiz is packed with over 1,000 brilliant questions to test your trivia knowledge against your friends and family. And from 1st of October to the 31st, you'll be able to pre-order a copy from Waterstones for half price using the code Rest 2025, Rest 2025, capital R that is. Pre-order your copy of the Restis quiz by Goldhanger from Waterstone using the code, Rest with a capital R, 2025. Now, Hello and welcome back to the rest is history. The Battle of Copenhagen is blazing. The Danish line is cracking. But in the rear, the elderly Admiral Parker, not one of Life's centre forwards, I think. He's always been anxious about probing the Danish defences too close. He's got cold feet. He's decided to call it a day and he has hoisted Signal 39 discontinued the action. So basically, just as Nelson is on the verge of winning a day, he's got cold feet. He's decided to call it a day and he has hoisted Signal 39 discontinued the action. So basically, just as Nelson is on the verge of winning a
《其余皆是政治》、《其余皆是机密》，当然还有《其余皆是足球》。《其余皆是问答》包含了1000多个精彩的问题，可以用来测试你和朋友家人之间的琐事知识。从10月1日到31日，你将能够以半价从Waterstones预订副本，使用代码Rest 2025，Rest 2025，大写R。使用代码Rest（大写R）2025，从Waterstone预订Goldhanger的《其余皆是问答》。现在，你好，欢迎回到《其余皆是历史》。哥本哈根战役正打得火热。丹麦防线正在崩溃。但在后方，年迈的帕克上将，我想他不是那种生活中的前锋。他一直担心过于接近丹麦的防御工事。他退缩了。他决定收手，并升起了第39号信号：停止战斗。所以基本上，就在纳尔逊即将赢得一场
decisive victory, he's saying, no, come back. So the massive question, Dominic, what's Nelson going to do? Well, he has to make of his mind straight away. He's got very, very little time because, of course, they're in the heat of battle. And I think his mind works fast. He weighs up the balance of forces. If he ignores the signal, ignores a direct order, he thinks, in fact, he's almost certain he can win. He knows the Danish line is cracking. He knows some of the guns are being put out of action. He knows that his men are well-trained, their fit, their experience, and the balance will tip in their favour all the time. Now, if he breaks off, under Danish fire, they have to retreat, get out of the Kings Deep, get around the shoals, and we join the rest of
决定性胜利的时候，他在说，不，回来吧。那么，多米尼克，最大的问题是，纳尔逊会怎么做？好吧，他必须立刻拿定主意。他几乎没有时间，因为当然，他们正处于激战之中。我认为他的大脑运转很快。他权衡了力量对比。如果他无视信号，无视直接命令，他认为，事实上，他几乎肯定自己能赢。他知道丹麦防线正在崩溃。他知道一些火炮已被摧毁。他知道他的部下训练有素，身体强健，经验丰富，天平会一直向他们倾斜。现在，如果他撤出，在丹麦人的炮火下，他们必须撤退，离开“国王深水区”，绕过浅滩，然后与其余的
the squadron. Yeah. And as they turn, then they're subject to kind of raking fire. So it's lethal. So, you know, clearly Nelson's instinct is absolutely to carry on fighting. But just to emphasize it is a big deal for an officer in the heat of battle any time but particularly in the heat of battle to ignore a direct order and should the battle not go well then this will be the end of Nelson's career
中队会合。是的。当他们转向时，他们会受到侧射火力的攻击。所以这是致命的。所以，你知道，显然纳尔逊的本能绝对是继续战斗。但要强调的是，对于一名军官来说，在激战中，任何时候，尤其是激战中，无视直接命令是一件大事，如果战斗进展不顺利，那么这将是纳尔逊职业生涯的终结。
yes it would exactly it would he does have form though so at the Battle of Cape St Vincent he had ignored Sir John Jervis's direct orders his plan he had gone out of the line and he had sort of launched this solo mission that basically changed the whole course of the battle
是的，确实如此。不过他确实有前科。在圣文森特角海战中，他无视了约翰·杰维斯爵士的直接命令，也就是他的计划，他脱离了战线，发起了一次单人任务，基本上改变了整个战斗的进程。
So sometimes, you know, when he backs his own judgment, it pays off. So it takes him just a moment and he mutters, Colonel Stewart hears him mutter under his breath. Leave off action. No, damn me if I do. And a lieutenant says, shall we repeat the signal? In other words, transmit the signal to the rest of our ships. Nelson says, acknowledge it, but do not repeat it. Keep signal 16 aloft.
所以有时，你知道，当他坚持自己的判断时，会有回报。所以他只花了一会儿时间，他嘟囔着，斯图尔特上校听到他低声嘟囔。停止战斗。不，该死，我才不干。一名中尉说，我们要重复这个信号吗？换句话说，把信号传达给我们的其余船只。纳尔逊说，确认它，但不要重复它。保持16号信号悬挂。
That is the signal, engage the enemy more closely. And the thing about that is, it's reflective of Nelson's confidence that he has more authority over the line of battle than the ostensible commander-in-chief does. And we will see if he's right to be that confident. Now, the other men on the quarter deck know that this is rank in subordination. I think it's pretty clear that Captain Foley is shocked by it because he effectively seems to ask for confirmation. Are you sure, sir, or something along those lines? or maybe he just raises an eyebrow, who knows. Now, what happens next?
那就是“更紧密地与敌人交战”的信号。关于这一点，它反映了纳尔逊的自信，他认为自己对战线的控制力比名义上的总司令还要大。我们将看看他是否有理由如此自信。现在，后甲板上的其他人知道这是公然抗命。我认为很明显，弗利船长对此感到震惊，因为他实际上似乎要求确认。您确定吗，长官，或者类似的话。或者也许他只是挑了挑眉毛，谁知道呢。现在，接下来发生了什么？
Here is the story that every British school child used to learn. And still should. Absolutely, they should. Let's be honest. Nelson says to Foley, you know, Foley, I have only one eye. I have a right to be blind sometimes. And then a great gesture, pure Nelsonian theatre, he reaches for a telescope and he puts it to his sightless eye.
这就是每个英国学童过去常学的故事。而且现在也应该学。老实说，他们确实应该学。纳尔逊对弗利说，你知道，弗利，我只有一只眼睛。我有权偶尔装瞎。然后是一个伟大的姿态，纯粹的纳尔逊式戏剧，他伸手去拿望远镜，把它放在他失明的眼睛上。
the one that can't see. And he says, I really do not see the signal. Now, the sad thing about this story is that some of Nelson's biographers, I'm sorry to say, let themselves down by doubting it. Isn't that right? I don't think it's sad, because I think it's up there with, you know, Alfred Burning the Cakes. Of course it is. Yeah. Robert the Bruce and the spider. It's Drake and the Armada. So the Armada arrives and Drake's playing a game of Bowls and he says, there's time to finish the game and beat the Armada too. And he does. And the thing is that all these stories, they have the power that they do because they're very dramatic, but also because they illustrate the truth of the circumstances. We've done Greek myths. I mean, myths have a power that isn't directly
那只看不见的眼睛。他说，我真的没看见那个信号。现在，关于这个故事可悲的是，纳尔逊的一些传记作者，我很遗憾地说，因为怀疑它而让自己失望了。不是吗？我不觉得可悲，因为我认为它和“阿尔弗雷德烧焦蛋糕”一样经典。当然是。是的。罗伯特·布鲁斯和蜘蛛。这是德雷克和无敌舰队。所以无敌舰队到了，德雷克正在玩草地滚球，他说，有时间打完比赛，也能打败无敌舰队。他确实做到了。关键是，所有这些故事之所以有力量，是因为它们非常戏剧化，但也因为它们说明了当时情况的真相。我们讲过希腊神话。我的意思是，神话有一种力量，并不直接
dependent on whether they are factually true or not. However, of course, historians are going to scoff at this kind of thing. But equally, there are those who say, well, you know, I think it's more likely this happened than that Alfred burnt his cakes, for instance. Absolutely. And actually, John Sugden, who's spent an enormous amount of ink on this particular story, looking at the provenance of it, all the different accounts. So basically, Colonel Stewart told his story about what happened on the quarterdeck several times in the next 10 years or so. And as so often with anecdotes, the anecdotes slightly changed in each telling. Improved, what I say? Yeah, it improved. But Sutton says, listen, you can doubt it and you can say, well, the very, very earliest stories
取决于它们在事实上是否真实。然而，当然，历史学家会对这种事情嗤之以鼻。但同样，也有人说，嗯，你知道，我认为这比阿尔弗雷德烧焦蛋糕更有可能发生。绝对是。事实上，约翰·萨格登，他在这个特定故事上花费了大量笔墨，研究了它的出处，所有不同的记载。所以基本上，斯图尔特上校在接下来的10年左右的时间里多次讲述了他关于后甲板上发生的事情的故事。正如轶事常有的那样，轶事在每次讲述中都会略有变化。改进了，我是这么说的？是的，改进了。但萨格登说，听着，你可以怀疑它，你可以说，嗯，关于后甲板上发生的事情的最早的故事
about what happened on the quarterdeck, don't mention it. But that doesn't mean that it didn't happen. does it have the ring of implausibility? I mean, it sounds perfectly plausible, right? That's the key. So Suggdon says the telescope story is entirely in Nelson's character. He never forgot his audience. And that could either mean that people assume it's true because it sounds right. Yes.
并没有提到它。但这并不意味着它没有发生。它听起来不可信吗？我的意思是，听起来完全可信，对吧？这就是关键。所以萨格登说，望远镜的故事完全符合纳尔逊的性格。他从不忘记他的观众。这既可以意味着人们认为它是真的，因为它听起来很对。是的。
But equally, it could be true because Nelson would do it. I mean, I think the one thing that's definitely not true is the kind of thing that you will often see on illustrations of this scene that shows Nelson raising his telescope to an eyepatch. And we have already emphasized Nelson did not wear a kind of pirate eye patch. But I think we've concluded, haven't we, Tom, that it absolutely happened. And in many ways, it happened more bravely than people have given Nelson credit for. I think so. So he's taken this incredible risk. And actually here is the ultimate demonstration of Nelson's reputation among his fellow captains. Everybody follows his lead. None of the other
但同样，它也可能是真的，因为纳尔逊确实会这么做。我的意思是，我认为唯一肯定不是真的事情，就是你经常在这一场景的插图中看到的，显示纳尔逊把望远镜举到眼罩上。我们已经强调过，纳尔逊并没有戴那种海盗眼罩。但我认为我们已经得出结论了，不是吗，汤姆，它绝对发生了。而且在许多方面，它发生得比人们给予纳尔逊的评价更勇敢。我想是的。所以他冒了这么大的险。事实上，这就是纳尔逊在其他船长中声望的终极证明。每个人都跟随他的领导。没有其他
warship captains question him. None of them break off the attack. Of course, in that case, they would be disobeying Nelson. And there's no recrimination afterwards. There is one captain who does obey Parker's orders. And this is Edward Ryu, who Nelson particularly admires. He's shown a great initiative. He's gone to the top of the line. But he is a very, very junior officer.
战舰船长质疑他。他们中没有一个人停止攻击。当然，那样的话，他们就是在违抗纳尔逊。事后也没有指责。有一位船长确实服从了帕克的命令。这就是爱德华·里尤，纳尔逊特别钦佩他。他表现出了极大的主动性。他已经到了战线的最前面。但他是一名非常、非常初级的军官。
It's a massive, massive deal for him, much more than for Nelson's more established captains to break an order. And so he very, very reluctantly gives his squadron of five ships the order to withdraw. I mean, he keeps on fighting for half an hour, but ultimately he thinks, you know, I've been given a direct order. I've got to obey it. And you were saying how had Nelson ordered a withdrawal, this would have been calamitous for the entire British line. And the fate of Rue illustrates this. Because what happens is that as his squadron of frigates starts to turn and withdraw and stop firing, the gun smoke clears. And Ryu's own ship, which is the last to withdraw, you know, there is no disguise now. It's open fire for the Danish gunners. And we have an account from Colonel Stewart, you know, who was with Nelson, who may or may not have seen him putting his telescope to his blind eye, who describes what happened. So this is Stuart on Ryu. He had expressed himself grieved at being obliged to retreat and nobly observed, what will Nelson think of us? His clerk was killed by his side. And by another shot, several marines while hauling on the main brace,
对他来说，这比纳尔逊那些更资深的船长违抗命令要严重得多。所以他非常、非常不情愿地给了他的五艘船中队撤退的命令。我的意思是，他继续战斗了半小时，但最终他想，你知道，我接到了直接命令。我必须服从它。你说过，如果纳尔逊下令撤退，这对整个英国战线来说将是灾难性的。而里尤的命运说明了这一点。因为发生的事情是，当他的护卫舰中队开始转向撤退并停止射击时，硝烟散去了。里尤自己的船，是最后一艘撤退的，你知道，现在没有任何掩护了。这对丹麦炮手来说是公开射击。我们有斯图尔特上校的记载，你知道，他和纳尔逊在一起，他可能看到了也可能没看到他把望远镜放在瞎眼上，他描述了发生的事情。所以这是斯图尔特关于里尤的描述。他表示对被迫撤退感到悲伤，并高尚地观察到，纳尔逊会怎么看我们？他的书记员在他身边被杀。另一枚炮弹在拉动主支索时，几名海军陆战队员
shared the same fate. Ryu then exclaimed, come then, my boys, let us all die together. The words were scarcely uttered when the fatal shot severed him into. Gosh, that's very moving. Yeah. How does Colonel Stuart know, by the way, because he's on a different ship? I imagine that it's reported to him. Listen, I'm never going to be skeptical about a story like this. Of course. I mean, again, what will Nelson think of us? Come then, my boys, let us all die together. Yeah. I mean, you might think these phrases are too good to be true. But I think it's striking that Ryu is a particular favourite of Nelson's. He's only met him on the course of this expedition. And clearly there is a kind of self-dramatizing quality to reuse heroism that Nelson really identifies with.
遭遇了同样的命运。里尤随后惊呼，来吧，我的小伙子们，让我们一起死吧。话音刚落，致命的炮弹就将他一分为二。天哪，这太感人了。是的。顺便问一下，斯图尔特上校是怎么知道的，因为他在另一艘船上？我想是有人向他报告的。听着，我永远不会对这样的故事持怀疑态度。当然。我的意思是，再次，纳尔逊会怎么看我们？来吧，我的小伙子们，让我们一起死吧。是的。我的意思是，你可能会认为这些短语好得令人难以置信。但我认为引人注目的是，里尤是纳尔逊特别喜欢的人。他只是在这次远征的过程中才认识他。显然，里尤的英雄主义有一种自我戏剧化的特质，纳尔逊对此非常有共鸣。
So again, I think it's perfectly plausible. He said that. Yeah, just like the telescope. The self-dramatizing is driven from the top. You have a man who is constructing his life as though he's on the stage, I would say. And so other people follow suit. And Nelson says that Ryu's loss is almost the worst loss of the battle, you know, that he would have gone on. to really great things. Right. So back at the harbour, it's about 2 o'clock, huge great clouds of black smoke. The air is thick with kind of screams and explosions.
所以再次，我认为这完全可信。他说了那话。是的，就像望远镜一样。这种自我戏剧化是从高层驱动的。你会有一个人，他构建自己的生活就像他在舞台上一样，我会说。所以其他人也效仿。纳尔逊说，里尤的损失几乎是这场战斗中最严重的损失，你知道，他本可以继续。取得伟大的成就。对。所以回到港口，大约是2点钟，巨大的黑烟云。空气中充满了尖叫声和爆炸声。
The Danes are fighting manfully, but they're in real trouble now. By about 2 o'clock, the Danabrog, their flagship is burning. By about 2.30, its gun crews have been completely slaughtered, and the flag comes down, and the survivors have to flee for the shore. The Danish commander is a bloke called Commodore Ulfert Fisher. and he's already moved his flag to another ship, the Holston, about the same time, that ship's overpowered as well, and he has to take refuge in one of the forts, the Treck-on-Earth fort. So it's very clear the British have the upper hand.
丹麦人英勇作战，但他们现在陷入了真正的麻烦。大约2点钟，他们的旗舰“丹内布罗格”号正在燃烧。大约2点30分，它的炮手被彻底屠杀，旗帜降下，幸存者不得不逃往岸边。丹麦指挥官是一个叫乌尔费特·费舍尔准将的人。他已经把他的旗帜移到了另一艘船“霍尔斯顿”号上，大约在同一时间，那艘船也被压制了，他不得不躲进其中一个堡垒，特雷克-昂-埃尔特堡垒。所以很明显，英国人占了上风。
They don't have things entirely their own way, though. I mean, this is still a really, you know, this is what makes Nelson's call so dicey, is that it's still pretty tight. And, you know, some of his ships, the monarch and the defiance are really taking terrible, terrible punishment. The Danish batteries are still intact. They're still firing relentlessly. And now I think Nelson does one of the most impressive things he ever did in a battle, because he's not just about get up close and batter them and then we'll win. He's also thinking politically. Yeah, he's an Achilles, but he's calculating Achilles. Exactly. So he goes down
不过，他们并没有完全随心所欲。我的意思是，这仍然是一个非常，你知道，这就是为什么纳尔逊的决定如此冒险，因为情况仍然非常紧张。而且，你知道，他的一些船，“君主”号和“蔑视”号正遭受着可怕的惩罚。丹麦炮台仍然完好无损。他们仍在无情地开火。现在我认为纳尔逊做出了他在战斗中做过的最令人印象深刻的事情之一，因为他不仅仅是关于靠近并猛击他们，然后我们就会赢。他也在进行政治思考。是的，他是一个阿喀琉斯，但他是一个精于算计的阿喀琉斯。正是如此。所以他下到
below for a second, and he scribbles a note that is basically offering the Danes a deal. And then he gives it to a bloke called Frederick Thessiger, who speaks Danish, and says, can you get in a little boat, go over to the shore, under a flag of truce, find Crown Prince Frederick, and give him this note. And Crown Prince Frederick is George III's nephew. Yes. So, you know, there are certain familial bonds. Exactly.
下面一会儿，他草拟了一张纸条，基本上是给丹麦人一个交易。然后他把它交给了一个叫弗雷德里克·塞西格的人，他会说丹麦语，并说，你能坐上一艘小船，去岸边，在休战旗帜下，找到王储弗雷德里克，把这张纸条交给他吗？而王储弗雷德里克是乔治三世的侄子。是的。所以，你知道，有一些家族纽带。正是如此。
Now, why did Nelson do this? Afterwards, he always said, I did it because basically I'm a very kind person, and I wanted to spare the Danes anymore. bloodshed. But you know, Dominic, I think that's true. I mean, it sounds counterintuitive. Nelson, he wants to practice battles of annihilation. But he does that for the broader purpose, I think. And if he had the option of not spilling blood, but still serving Britain, then he would do that. And it was striking that in the peace negotiations that culminates in the Treaty of Amiens, Nelson's backing it. He wants peace. And I think it's important for people to bear that in mind. He is not animated by a bloodlust. I think that's right.
现在，纳尔逊为什么要这么做？事后，他总是说，我这么做是因为基本上我是一个非常善良的人，我想让丹麦人免受更多的流血。但你知道，多米尼克，我认为那是真的。我的意思是，这听起来有悖常理。纳尔逊，他想进行歼灭战。但我认为他这样做是为了更广泛的目的。如果他有选择不流血但仍然为英国服务，那么他会那样做。令人震惊的是，在以《亚眠和约》告终的和平谈判中，纳尔逊支持它。他想要和平。我认为人们记住这一点很重要。他不是被嗜血所驱动的。我认为那是对的。
He later told Henry Addington, who became Prime Minister. He said to Addington, those Danish ships that had surrendered were trapped in the killing zone. They couldn't get away. And they're being hit by friendly fire from their own batteries. It was a massacre, a site which no real man could have enjoyed. I felt when the Danes became my prisoners, I became their protector. In other words, loads of Danes are being killed in the crossfire, and I want to save them.
他后来告诉亨利·阿丁顿，也就是后来的首相。他对阿丁顿说，那些投降的丹麦船只被困在杀戮区。他们无法逃脱。他们正受到自己炮台的友军炮火的打击。那是一场屠杀，一个任何真正的人都不会享受的景象。当丹麦人成为我的俘虏时，我感到我成了他们的保护者。换句话说，大量的丹麦人在交火中被杀，我想拯救他们。
And he actually wrote to Emma, didn't he, and said, Nelson is a warrior, but he will not be a butcher. Really good sign that he's talking about himself in the third person, I think. Like Caesar. Yeah. I mean, you wouldn't get Caesar saying that. So I think we can agree that this reflects very well on Nelson. Listeners can admire him wholeheartedly on this.
他实际上写信给艾玛，不是吗，说，纳尔逊是一名战士，但他不会成为一名屠夫。他以第三人称谈论自己，这真是一个很好的迹象，我想。像凯撒一样。是的。我的意思是，你不会听到凯撒那样说。所以我认为我们可以同意，这反映了纳尔逊非常好的一面。听众可以全心全意地钦佩他。
He's absolutely right. You see, Napoleon is a butcher. Napoleon, when he invades Italy, leaves a trail of looted and pillaged villages and blood and whatnot and actually wants to terrify the civilian population. into remaining compliant. Nelson has no real history of that. His critics might say Naples, but I think Naples stands out as the most controversial episode in his career precisely because it's unusual. Because it's unusual, yeah. Some of his own officers, I have to say, thought there was something slightly more to it. So Hardy said, for example, it's not just about
他是绝对正确的。你看，拿破仑是一个屠夫。拿破仑在入侵意大利时，留下了被洗劫和掠夺的村庄、鲜血等等，实际上是想恐吓平民人口。使其保持顺从。纳尔逊没有那样的历史。他的批评者可能会说那不勒斯，但我认为那不勒斯是他职业生涯中最具争议的事件，恰恰因为它是不寻常的。因为它是不寻常的，是的。我必须说，他自己的一些军官认为这背后还有点别的东西。所以哈迪说，例如，这不仅仅是关于
humanitarianism. He wanted to get off the prizes, the Danish prizes that hadn't been sunk or burnt, and he also was doing it to protect his own ships. This is hardly talking, five of which at this time were on shore within gunshot of the batteries. In other words, they were sort of trapped on the shoals. Colonel Stewart, he wrote about this. He said it was, quote, a masterpiece of policy. It was the only way for Nelson to save those grounded British ships. They got stuck, and they were in, quote, a most perilous situation. And most historians have written about this say, you know, whatever the swirl of motives that went into this, it was really, really canny.
人道主义。他想摆脱那些没有被击沉或烧毁的丹麦战利品，他这样做也是为了保护他自己的船只。这是哈迪在说，当时有五艘船在岸边，在炮台的射程之内。换句话说，他们被困在浅滩上。斯图尔特上校，他写了关于这件事的文章。他说这是，引用，政策的杰作。这是纳尔逊拯救那些搁浅的英国船只的唯一方法。他们被困住了，他们处于，引用，一个最危险的境地。大多数写过这件事的历史学家都说，你知道，无论是什么动机促成了这一点，它确实非常、非常精明。
One of his supreme battle decisions, says Roger Knight. So this boat, Thessiger, he arrives at the Citadel in Copenhagen, he takes the note to the Crown Prince. And Nelson, it's a masterpiece of diplomacy, because Nelson has addressed it to, and I quote, the brothers of Englishmen, the Danes, no high praise. And he says, I will absolutely flatten you if I have to, but I really, really don't want to. I'd rather save the brave Danes who have defended your forts. And he says to the Crown Prince, I'd love to make a deal with you. Peace and friendship with Denmark would be the greatest victory
罗杰·奈特说，这是他最高明的战斗决策之一。所以这艘船，塞西格，他到达了哥本哈根的城堡，他把纸条带给了王储。而纳尔逊，这是一个外交杰作，因为纳尔逊把它写给了，我引用，英国人的兄弟，丹麦人，没有高调的赞美。他说，如果必须的话，我会彻底夷平你们，但我真的、真的不想。我宁愿拯救那些保卫你们堡垒的勇敢的丹麦人。他对王储说，我很乐意与你达成协议。与丹麦的和平与友谊将是我赢得的最伟大的胜利。
that I've ever gained. A dry eye in the house. Yeah. And the Crown Prince is an intelligent guy. He can see that this is the perfect way to save his men, to save Copenhagen, the city and there's dockyards from assault, and to keep his honour. It's basically a good outcome for the Danes. And presumably also, the issue for the Danes is that they don't want to be attacked by the French, or indeed the Russians. So essentially, they've put up a good enough show that they can say to the French and Russian ministers, well, you know, we did our best, but what choice did we have. I mean, because ultimately, they're not really committed to the war against Britain. No. They had to choose between France and Britain.
屋子里没有干眼。是的。而王储是一个聪明人。他能看出这是拯救他的部下、拯救哥本哈根这座城市及其造船厂免受攻击，并保持其荣誉的完美方式。这对丹麦人来说基本上是一个好的结果。而且大概，丹麦人的问题是他们不想被法国人或俄罗斯人攻击。所以基本上，他们表现得足够好，可以对法国和俄罗斯部长说，嗯，你知道，我们尽力了，但我们有什么选择呢。我的意思是，因为最终，他们并没有真正致力于对英国的战争。不。他们必须在法国和英国之间做出选择。
They chose France because they thought the French were more of a threat. So in a way, they don't want to lose lots of lives. so they don't want to have their capital city demolished in the cause of a war with Britain. This is a great outcome for the Danes. As we will see, I was about to say, they should be thanking us. As we will see, they kind of do. So the Crown Prince says fine, we'll have a ceasefire, we'll open some talks, and it takes about half an hour for the fighting to die down and the battle is over.
他们选择了法国，因为他们认为法国人的威胁更大。所以从某种意义上说，他们不想失去大量的生命。所以他们不想让他们的首都城市因为与英国的战争而被摧毁。这对丹麦人来说是一个伟大的结果。正如我们将看到的，我正要说，他们应该感谢我们。正如我们将看到的，他们确实感谢了。所以王储说好吧，我们将停火，我们将进行一些谈判，战斗平息大约需要半小时，战斗就结束了。
So in all, the British have lost about 250 men killed. The Danes have lost about 500. They've lost two ships completely destroyed, and 12 of their ships have been captured. Not a huge amount, you might say, but this is a small country. So this is a heavy toll. Yeah. And the ferocity of the fighting, the intensity of the carnage was of a quality that a lot of the experienced British sailors said, you know, this was in a different league from the Nile even or Capes and Vincent or something. I think because it's such a tight channel, such withering fire, such close range action.
所以总共，英国人损失了大约250人阵亡。丹麦人损失了大约500人。他们损失了两艘船被彻底摧毁，12艘船被俘获。你可能会说数量不多，但这只是一个小国。所以这是一个沉重的代价。是的。战斗的激烈程度，屠杀的强度，达到了许多经验丰富的英国水手所说的，你知道，这甚至比尼罗河海战或圣文森特角海战等还要高出一个档次。我想是因为这是一个如此狭窄的通道，如此猛烈的火力，如此近距离的战斗。
So many bodies kind of bobbing everywhere. Yeah. Blood and the water. I mean, a hideous. Captain Fremantle, Thomas Fremantle, had been in two of Nelson's fights before. He'd been in the Battle of Over the Satira, if you remember that in the 1790s, and the Nile. And he said the carnage on board, the Danish vessels exceeds anything I ever heard of. And everybody in the British fleet said, God, the Danes, they really fought well.
到处都是漂浮的尸体。是的。水里的血。我的意思是，太可怕了。弗里曼特尔船长，托马斯·弗里曼特尔，之前参加过两次纳尔逊的战斗。如果你还记得1790年代的萨蒂拉战役和尼罗河海战，他都参加过。他说丹麦船上的屠杀超过了我听说过的任何事情。英国舰队里的每个人都说，上帝，丹麦人，他们真的打得很好。
So one of Nelson's men, Thomas Wilkes, wrote home, says, I will do the Danes, the credit to say they fought well. far better than I've ever found from the French or the Spaniards. Well, the Danes are not a serious enemy for the British, unlike the French or the Spaniards. So in a sense, by praising the Danes relative to them or serious enemies, it's a good propaganda twist, isn't it? It is indeed. So Nelson is absolutely shattered, isn't he? Because he hasn't been sleeping, and not surprisingly, because he's been so stressed. So just to talk about what Nelson does after the battle, and to put it in the context of what he's been doing over the previous two days,
所以纳尔逊的一个部下，托马斯·威尔克斯，写信回家说，我会给丹麦人应有的赞誉，说他们打得很好。远比我从法国人或西班牙人那里发现的要好。好吧，丹麦人对英国人来说不是严重的敌人，不像法国人或西班牙人。所以从某种意义上说，通过赞美丹麦人相对于他们或严重的敌人，这是一个很好的宣传转折，不是吗？确实如此。所以纳尔逊绝对是精疲力竭了，不是吗？因为他一直没睡觉，而且不足为奇，因为他压力太大了。所以只是谈谈纳尔逊在战斗后做了什么，并把它放在他过去两天所做的事情的背景下，
he's been preparing his battle plans. He stayed up all night drawing them and getting them ready with Captain Ryu. He has led and fought a great battle. He's suffered physical danger. He's been tormented by the tension of knowing whether his plans are going to come off or not. He's witnessed hideous carnage. He's directly disobeyed an order from his superior. He's done this kind of diplomatic gambit of opening negotiations with the Danes. He has secured a stunning, overwhelming victory against all the odds. He's gazed at the horrors of the straits, the seas littered with corpses, mourning the losses both of his own sailors and those of the Danes, which made his heart run out of his eyes, quoting there. He has returned from the elephant to his cabin on the St. George, because he can sail back and get on his original flagship. He's gone to his cabin. He's taken out his journal.
他一直在准备他的战斗计划。他整夜没睡，画出它们，并和里尤船长一起准备好。他领导并打了一场伟大的战斗。他遭受了身体上的危险。他一直被那种不知道他的计划是否会成功的紧张感所折磨。他目睹了可怕的屠杀。他直接违抗了上级的命令。他做了这种与丹麦人进行谈判的外交策略。他克服了所有困难，取得了惊人的、压倒性的胜利。他凝视着海峡的恐怖，海上到处都是尸体，哀悼他自己的水手和丹麦人的损失，这让他心如刀割，引用那句话。他从“象”号回到了他在“圣乔治”号上的船舱，因为他可以航行回去并回到他原来的旗舰上。他去了他的船舱。他拿出了他的日志。
He's recorded the details of the day. He then records that he felt very unwell, unsurprisingly. And then, after all that, he reaches for a piece of paper, picks up his pen, and he writes a letter to Emma, accusing her of keeping scandalous company with the Prince of Wales. That's his priority. After all that, works himself up into an absolute state. And he's on the verge of collapsing. And then he calms down and he writes Emma a poem. East, west, north, south, our minds shall never part. Your angels loadstone shall be Nelson's heart. And having written that, he then lies down on his cot and passes out and sleeps for about six hours. I just think it's the most Nelson. series of events you could possibly imagine. It is. It's the combination of unbelievable heroism and achievement combined with a kind of comical erotic obsession. Well, not only of that, Tom, but the Prince of Wales, the future George IV, one of the worst men who ever lived,
他记录了这一天的细节。然后他记录说他感到非常不舒服，这不足为奇。然后，在所有这些之后，他伸手去拿一张纸，拿起他的笔，他写了一封信给艾玛，指责她与威尔士亲王保持着丑闻般的交往。那是他的优先事项。在所有这些之后，把自己搞得处于一种绝对的状态。他处于崩溃的边缘。然后他冷静下来，给艾玛写了一首诗。东西南北，我们的心永远不会分开。你的天使磁石将是纳尔逊的心。写完之后，他躺在行军床上昏了过去，睡了大约六个小时。我只是认为这是你能想象到的最纳尔逊的一系列事件。确实是。这是令人难以置信的英雄主义和成就与一种滑稽的色情痴迷的结合。好吧，不仅如此，汤姆，威尔士亲王，未来的乔治四世，有史以来最糟糕的人之一，
is living rent-free in Nelson's head, isn't he? It's the first thing he thinks somebody gets back to his cabin. Right. So he has this sleep. The next day, the third of April, he and Hardy go ashore to negotiate personally with the Crown Prince. And this really is a lovely scene. This is why they should make a film of this. They land at the South Customs House Key in Copenhagen, and there are huge crowds waiting, and the Crown Prince has sent guards to escort them. But actually, they don't need the guards, because the crowds are so friendly. Nelson is a celebrity. This is the weird thing. He's attacked their capital, but people are quite excited to see him. They're offered a carriage, and they say, well, no, we don't need the carriage. So they war.
住在纳尔逊的脑子里，不用付房租，不是吗？这是他回到船舱后想到的第一件事。对。所以他睡了一觉。第二天，4月3日，他和哈迪上岸亲自与王储谈判。这真是一个可爱的场景。这就是为什么他们应该拍一部关于这个的电影。他们在哥本哈根的南关税局码头登陆，有大量人群在等待，王储派了卫兵护送他们。但实际上，他们不需要卫兵，因为人群非常友好。纳尔逊是一个名人。这是奇怪的事情。他袭击了他们的首都，但人们很高兴见到他。他们被提供了一辆马车，他们说，嗯，不，我们不需要马车。所以他们走
down the main street towards the palace. And Hardy says that Nelson was received with as much admiration as when we went to the Lord Mayor's show in London. And does Nelson enjoy this? Of course he does. Because he does. Nelson loves it. He writes afterwards, quite rightly,
沿着主街走向宫殿。哈迪说，纳尔逊受到的欢迎和我们去伦敦市长秀时一样受到钦佩。纳尔逊喜欢这个吗？他当然喜欢。因为他喜欢。纳尔逊喜欢它。他事后写道，非常正确，
I am spoiled. All my astonishment is that my head is not turned. Oh, it's such modesty. Such humility. It's nice for him to compliment himself on his own level-headedness. Anyway, they get into see the Crown Prince. And Nelson says, look, why are you in bed with the Russians? That's a terrible decision. You know, we are your true friends. And his argument is the Russians have misled you.
我被宠坏了。我所有的惊讶是我的头没有转过来。哦，真是谦虚。真是谦逊。他称赞自己头脑冷静真是太好了。无论如何，他们进去见王储。纳尔逊说，看，你为什么要和俄罗斯人同床共枕？那是一个糟糕的决定。你知道，我们是你真正的朋友。他的论点是俄罗斯人误导了你。
We're never going to accept this arm neutrality stuff. Our national survival depends on us being able to, you know, have these blockades. It's the only way we can fight the French. I mean, I suppose that's true. Yeah. But the issue for the Danes remains that the Russians are much closer than the British. Yeah. And, you know, the French are even more menacing than that. Right, and the Danes want to trade and they want to do all this. So the talks, they go on for a few days, so long, in fact, that Nelson is able to bunk off to the Royal Copenhagen Porcelain Company, where he orders a dinner service for Emma. Brilliant. So again, his laser focused on the main issues.
我们永远不会接受这种武装中立的东西。我们的国家生存取决于我们能够，你知道，进行这些封锁。这是我们对抗法国人的唯一方法。我的意思是，我想那是真的。是的。但丹麦人的问题仍然是俄罗斯人比英国人近得多。是的。而且，你知道，法国人比那更具威胁性。对，丹麦人想贸易，他们想做所有这些事情。所以谈判，他们进行了几天，事实上太久了，以至于纳尔逊能够溜到皇家哥本哈根瓷器公司，在那里他为艾玛订购了一套餐具。太棒了。所以再次，他的激光聚焦在主要问题上。
And then on the sixth day of talks, which is the 8th of April, it's a terrible day, pouring rain, very miserable. Actually, when Nelson and his officials turn up at the palace, they're so bedraggled, they have to stand. by the fire for ages to dry out before they can be shown into the meeting. They get in and the crown prince says, okay, fine, we've got a deal. We will remain neutral for the next few months. That'll give you time to deal with the Russians. Now, in return, we will resupply you and restock your ships and stuff. You have to buy it all from us. We're happy to do that. Nelson says, brilliant. What a great deal this is. Now, only afterwards does he find out why they've come to the deal because they know something that he doesn't.
然后在谈判的第六天，也就是4月8日，这是一个糟糕的日子，倾盆大雨，非常悲惨。事实上，当纳尔逊和他的官员出现在宫殿时，他们是如此狼狈，他们不得不站在火炉旁很久才能晾干，然后才能被带进会议室。他们进去了，王储说，好吧，没问题，我们达成协议了。我们将在接下来的几个月里保持中立。那将给你时间去对付俄罗斯人。现在，作为回报，我们将重新供应你并重新储备你的船只等等。你必须全部从我们这里购买。我们很乐意这样做。纳尔逊说，太棒了。这是一个多么伟大的交易。现在，只有事后他才发现他们为什么达成协议，因为他们知道一些他不知道的事情。
The Crown Prince has had intelligence from St. Petersburg, bombshell news. So you described Tsar Paul I first. He's a very strange and disagreeable, man, with his obsession with people wearing the wrong hats and waistcoats and things. It's so what you want from a mad, sir. And Russian officers have been plotting against him for months, and they finally acted. They burst into his apartment at St. Michael's Castle in St. Petersburg.
王储从圣彼得堡得到了情报，重磅新闻。所以你描述了沙皇保罗一世。他是一个非常奇怪和令人不快的人，他痴迷于人们戴错帽子和背心之类的事情。这正是你从一个疯狂的沙皇那里想要的。俄罗斯军官已经密谋反对他好几个月了，他们终于采取了行动。他们闯入他在圣彼得堡圣迈克尔城堡的公寓。
They cornered him in his bedroom He was hiding behind the curtains They dragged him out They beat him over the head with a paperweight And then they strangled him to death with his own scarf They're quite resputin Well it's just standard Russian political behaviour, no So basically the League of Arm neutrality
他们把他逼到卧室的角落里，他躲在窗帘后面，他们把他拖出来，他们用镇纸敲他的头，然后他们用他自己的围巾把他勒死了。他们相当拉斯普京。好吧，这只是标准的俄罗斯政治行为，不是吗？所以基本上，武装中立联盟
That he had set up is now doomed And in fact his successor Alexander I Who ends up changing sides multiple times In the Napoleonic Wars One of his first acts is to make peace with Britain. A good start to the rain. Yeah, sensible policies for a happier Russia.
他所建立的一切现在注定要失败，事实上，他的继任者亚历山大一世在拿破仑战争中多次倒戈，他上任后的首要举措之一就是与英国讲和。这对统治来说是个好的开始。是的，为了一个更幸福的俄罗斯，这是明智的政策。
So all's well that ends well. There's only one person who's slightly down in the dumps. And guess who that is? It is, of course, Nelson. Is he complaining about how ill he feels? Yeah. So he sinks immediately into massive self-pity, hypochondria, complaining about headaches and his eyes and all this sort of thing.
所以结局好一切都好。只有一个人有点闷闷不乐。猜猜是谁？当然是纳尔逊。他在抱怨自己感觉有多糟糕吗？是的。所以他立刻陷入了巨大的自怜和疑病症中，抱怨头痛、眼睛疼以及所有这类事情。
I mean, to be fair to him, it's not quite over yet, Because when the deal is done with the Danes, he doesn't know that the Russians are about to pull out. And in fact, he thinks the Swedes are still involved. So he spends ages sailing around the Baltic, kind of looking for the Swedes in this terrible weather. And he ends up commander-in-chief of the British fleet because poor old Sir Hyde Parker has been recalled because news of the order that he gave Nelson has come out and people blame him for giving it rather than blame Nelson for disobeying it. And it has to be said that Nelson's very decent. He never mentions it.
说实话，对他公平一点说，事情还没完全结束，因为当与丹麦人的协议达成时，他并不知道俄国人即将退出。事实上，他以为瑞典人还参与其中。所以他在波罗的海航行了很久，在这种恶劣的天气里寻找瑞典人。他最终成为了英国舰队的总司令，因为可怜的老海德·帕克爵士被召回了，因为他给纳尔逊下达命令的消息传了出来，人们责怪他下达了命令，而不是责怪纳尔逊违抗命令。必须说，纳尔逊非常体面。他从不提起这件事。
I think it's Colonel Stewart who let's slip about it. He's always telling stories, isn't he? But then when Nelson's looking for the Swedes, we get one of the best ever Nelson's stories, which is actually reproduced in the Peter Weir Master and Commander film. So he's out in a little boat, isn't he? The boat is from HMS Bellona, and they're looking for the Swedes.
我想是斯图尔特上校说漏了嘴。他总是喜欢讲故事，不是吗？但当纳尔逊寻找瑞典人时，我们听到了纳尔逊最精彩的故事之一，这实际上在彼得·威尔的电影《怒海争锋》中重现了。他当时在一条小船上，对吧？那条船来自“贝罗纳”号，他们正在寻找瑞典人。
And the master of the boat said afterwards, it was extremely cold, and I wished him to put on a great coat of mine, which was in the boat. And Nelson said to him, No, I am not called. My anxiety for my country will keep me warm. It's zeal for king and country.
船长后来回忆说，当时非常冷，我希望他穿上我的一件大衣，那件大衣就在船上。纳尔逊对他说：“不，我不冷。我对国家的焦虑会让我保持温暖。”这是对国王和国家的狂热。
In the film it's zeal for king and country. And Russell Crow says, if it was any other man, you'd say, this is poor stuff. But with Nelson, you believe it. Yeah, you felt your heart glow. See, it's brilliant. But it is mad from Nelson, isn't it? If he's that ill and he's going out on the Baltic Sea without a coat. Yeah.
在电影里是“对国王和国家的狂热”。罗素·克劳说，如果是别人，你会说这太虚伪了。但对于纳尔逊，你会相信。是的，你会感到内心澎湃。看，这太棒了。但纳尔逊这样做很疯狂，不是吗？如果他病得那么重，还不穿大衣就出海到波罗的海。
I mean, he's asking for it, really. Yeah, it's great stuff that we can laugh about it now. But at the time, he nearly dies because he's got this fever. He's coughing so badly that everyone thinks he's got TB. He's having what he calls heart strokes. Hard to work out what these are. They're almost like panic attacks, I think. Palpitations or something, I guess.
我的意思是，他真的是自找的。是的，现在我们可以拿它开玩笑了，这很好。但在当时，他差点死了，因为他得了这种热病。他咳嗽得太厉害，以至于每个人都以为他得了肺结核。他出现了他所谓的“心脏中风”。很难弄清楚那是什么。我想那几乎就像恐慌发作。心悸之类的吧，我猜。
Yeah. And his officers are really worried about him. And actually, when people go back to London, they say, you've got to recall Nelson from the Baltic. I mean, if you leave him out there, he will die. Well, it's funny because the Earl of St. Vincent, said to John Jervis, who knows Nelson obviously incredibly well, when these reports that Nelson's ill arrive in London, to begin with, he says absolutely nothing to worry about.
是的。他的军官们真的很担心他。实际上，当人们回到伦敦时，他们说，你必须把纳尔逊从波罗的海召回来。我的意思是，如果你把他留在那里，他会死的。嗯，这很有趣，因为圣文森特伯爵对约翰·杰维斯说，他显然非常了解纳尔逊，当这些关于纳尔逊生病的报告传到伦敦时，起初，他说完全不用担心。
So he tells the king, Nelson is always in the habit of complaining of ill health, you know, with the implication, just ignore it. And then a week later, the reports are so serious that he becomes alarmed too, and wheels are set in motion, and Nelson is brought back. So the orders reach him in midsummer,
所以他告诉国王，纳尔逊习惯于抱怨健康状况不佳，你知道，言下之意就是，别理他。然后一周后，报告变得如此严重，以至于他也感到惊慌，于是开始采取行动，纳尔逊被带了回来。所以命令在仲夏时分传达到他手中，
and by the 29th of July, he lands in Yarmouth. Once again, greeted by huge crowds, ringing bells, all of this stuff. It's actually quite similar to the scene nine months earlier when he'd landed with the Hamilton's, the difference is there was a huge shadow that time, and there isn't the same shadow this time.
到7月29日，他在雅茅斯登陆。再次受到大批人群的欢迎，钟声齐鸣，所有这些。这实际上与九个月前他与汉密尔顿夫妇一起登陆时的场景非常相似，不同的是那次笼罩着巨大的阴影，而这次没有同样的阴影。
I mean, Emma is waiting for him. And of course, this saga, the Emma Fanny saga, is not quite over. Nelson, Emma has been on his mind every minute of every day, hasn't she? And he's sent her tons of presents. Well, he's got all that porcelain set from Copenhagen. Porcelain, bottles of wine, Danish wine, that's an odd... Yeah, I mean, that's mad. going to Scandinavia to buy wine.
我的意思是，艾玛在等他。当然，这个传奇，艾玛与范妮的传奇，还没有完全结束。纳尔逊，艾玛每天每时每刻都在他的脑海里，不是吗？他给她寄了成吨的礼物。嗯，他有那套从哥本哈根买的瓷器。瓷器，瓶装酒，丹麦酒，那真是奇怪……是的，我的意思是，那太疯狂了。去斯堪的纳维亚买酒。
Yeah, that's that. I've only just thought that. Not showing Nelson at his most astute. That's the worst decision that Nelson ever made. I mean, Cronenberg, perhaps. And he's also bought her lots of prints for her Nelson room. And in the next episode, we shall be getting into the decor of their house, which is, I think, alarming. But would go down very well, I think, with the current incumbents of the White House.
是的，就是那样。我刚才才想到。这并没有显示出纳尔逊最精明的一面。那是纳尔逊做过的最糟糕的决定。我的意思是，克罗嫩伯格，也许吧。他还为她的“纳尔逊房间”买了很多版画。在下一集中，我们将讨论他们房子的装饰，我认为这很令人震惊。但我认为，这会很受白宫现任住户的欢迎。
Now, sad to say, poor Fanny Nelson's wife has not quite given up hope of winning him back. So when he won the Battle of Copenhagen, she wrote him a letter of congratulation, which he completely and utterly ignored. And Edmund, his father, wrote to tell him off and said, Fanny, your wife was heavily affected with her personal feelings and not receiving a line from your own hand. And Nelson said to his father, I don't care. My mind is fixed.
现在，令人遗憾的是，可怜的范妮·纳尔逊夫人还没有完全放弃赢回他的希望。所以当他赢得哥本哈根战役时，她写了一封祝贺信给他，但他完全彻底地忽略了。埃德蒙，他的父亲，写信责备他，说：“范妮，你的妻子因为没有收到你亲笔写的一行字而深受个人情感的影响。”纳尔逊对他的父亲说：“我不在乎。我的心意已决。”
I want to be left to myself and without any inquire. from her. And Fanny still hasn't really got the message or hasn't given up because she sent his friend Alexander Davison what I find a very, very sad and moving letter. She said when she heard Nelson was coming home, my heart was all thankfulness and pleasure. But a moment's unwelcome and intruding reflection made me truly a miserable and pitiable being. I love him. I would do anything in the world to convince him of my affection. And then I think this is the very sad bit, she says surely i have angered him it was done unconsciously and without the least intention but my wish my desire was to please him and if you will have the goodness to send for me
“我想独自一人，不受她的任何询问。”范妮仍然没有真正明白，或者没有放弃，因为她给他的朋友亚历山大·戴维森写了一封我发现非常、非常悲伤和感人的信。她说当她听说纳尔逊要回家时，“我的心充满了感激和喜悦。但片刻间不受欢迎和闯入的思绪让我变成了一个真正悲惨和可怜的人。我爱他。我愿意做世界上任何事情来让他相信我的感情。”然后我认为这是最悲伤的部分，她说：“肯定是我惹恼了他，这是无意识地做的，没有任何意图，但我的愿望，我的渴望是取悦他，如果你能好心派人接我，
i will make it my study to obey him in every wish she just doesn't get there's nothing she can do so at the weekend i went to number one london absolutely house where the duke of wellington had his house and they had an exhibition on him and they talked about his relationship with his wife like nelson found fanny wellington found his wife boring and i think think it was very similar that Wellington like Nelson spends long periods abroad and he lives his life at an excruciating pitch. And I suspect that in both cases, they come to feel that their wives are boring, that they don't inhabit the same kind of zone. They're not part of the vibe of excitement and heroism and glamour that overseas service offers them. And in Nelson's
我会以服从他的每一个愿望为己任。”她就是不明白，她什么也做不了。所以周末我去了伦敦一号，也就是威灵顿公爵的住所，他们举办了一个关于他的展览，他们谈到了他与妻子的关系。就像纳尔逊发现范妮一样，威灵顿发现他的妻子很无聊，我认为这非常相似，威灵顿像纳尔逊一样，在国外度过了很长一段时间，他以一种极度紧张的状态生活。我怀疑在这两种情况下，他们都开始觉得他们的妻子很无聊，她们不属于同一个领域。她们不是海外服役所提供的兴奋、英雄主义和魅力氛围的一部分。而在纳尔逊的
case, Emma does. He replies to all the demands that he see Fanny and says that he's committed to building his life around a wife more suited to my genius. Yeah. I don't think you could get away with saying that today. Could you? I mean, people would think very poorly of you. I think you can if you're Nelson. Maybe. I mean, obviously, it's terrible. He treats Fanny terribly. You know, we've gone through that. At the same time, I guess you're with someone you find boring. You meet someone who you find intoxicating. What are you going to do? Yeah. Do you know Who agrees with you, Theo, because he's written in the chat, enough about Fanny. It's poor from Theo. Right. So since Theo is our overlord, we'll get to the end. On the 1st of July, Nelson arrived back in London and he goes straight to the Admiralty. Now, in the eyes of the Admiralty, he has redeemed himself. He has upheld Britain's national security. He has reaffirmed the Royal Navy's command of the seas. And there's never any whisper, is there, of criticism for him about disobeying orders? No, just like Cape St Vincent. If you're you gamble and it pays off, you're laughing. And he's done it not just by killing, but by
案例中，艾玛做到了。他回复了所有要求他见范妮的请求，并说他致力于围绕一个“更适合我天才”的妻子来建立自己的生活。是的。我不认为你今天能逃脱这种说法。对吧？我的意思是，人们会认为你很糟糕。我想如果你是纳尔逊，你可以。也许吧。我的意思是，显然，这很糟糕。他对待范妮很糟糕。你知道，我们已经讨论过了。与此同时，我想如果你和一个你觉得无聊的人在一起。你遇到了一个让你觉得陶醉的人。你会怎么做？是的。你知道谁同意你的观点吗，西奥，因为他在聊天中写道，关于范妮的已经够多了。这对西奥来说很糟糕。好吧，既然西奥是我们的霸主，我们就讲到最后。7月1日，纳尔逊回到伦敦，他直接去了海军部。现在，在海军部的眼里，他已经救赎了自己。他维护了英国的国家安全。他重申了皇家海军对海洋的控制权。从来没有任何关于他违抗命令的批评，对吧？没有，就像圣文森特角一样。如果你赌博并且成功了，你就在笑。他不仅通过杀戮，而且通过
diplomacy. I mean, that's the really impressive thing about Nelson at Copenhagen. You know, he's proved himself a politician as well as a warrior. But when he gets to the Admiralty, long faces greet him because while he has been away, there has been bombshell intelligence from across the channel. Because while Nelson has been in the Baltic, the new First Consul of France, Napoleon Bonaparte has been raising an enormous new army. And this time, I am sorry to say Bonaparte's target is not Naples or Constantinople or Egypt. His cruel and greedy eyes are set on the coast of England. Absolute scenes.
外交做到了这一点。我的意思是，这是纳尔逊在哥本哈根最令人印象深刻的地方。你知道，他证明了自己既是一位政治家，也是一位战士。但当他到达海军部时，迎接他的是一张张长脸，因为在他离开期间，海峡对岸传来了重磅情报。因为当纳尔逊在波罗的海时，法国的新第一执政拿破仑·波拿巴一直在组建一支庞大的新军队。这一次，我很遗憾地说，波拿巴的目标不是那不勒斯、君士坦丁堡或埃及。他那残忍而贪婪的眼睛盯着英国的海岸。绝对的场景。
So will Napoleon try an evasion of England? Will Nelson be able to stop him? There is literally only one way to find out. And that is to listen to our next episode, which will be out on Thursday. if you are not a club member, but if you are a club member, you can hear that and the final two episodes of this epic series straight away. And if you're not a club member and you would like to be able to hear these episodes immediately, then you just have to go to the rest of history dot com and sign up there. And of course, it comes with a whole slew of additional benefits,
那么拿破仑会尝试入侵英国吗？纳尔逊能阻止他吗？真的只有一种方法可以找到答案。那就是收听我们的下一集，它将在周四播出。如果你不是俱乐部会员，但如果你是俱乐部会员，你可以立即听到这一集以及这个史诗系列最后两集。如果你不是俱乐部会员，并且你想立即听到这些剧集，那么你只需要去therestishistory.com注册即可。当然，它还附带了一大堆额外的好处，
doesn't it, Dominic, one of which this week coming out on Friday, I will be talking to Mary beard about another great military commander, Julia Caesar. So just sensational value, as we've said. Wonderful stuff. Dominic, thanks so much for that. We will be back with Napoleon's greedy eyes set on England, and we will see you then. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Hello, I'm Gordon Carrera, National Security Journalist. And I'm David McClars. former CIA analyst turns spy novelist. And together we're the host of another goalhanger show called The Rest is Classified, where we bring you the best stories from the world of secrets and spars.
不是吗，多米尼克，其中之一是本周五即将推出的，我将与玛丽·比尔德谈论另一位伟大的军事指挥官，朱利叶斯·凯撒。所以正如我们所说，这真是太有价值了。精彩的内容。多米尼克，非常感谢。我们将带着拿破仑盯着英国的贪婪目光回来，到时候见。再见。再见。你好，我是戈登·卡雷拉，国家安全记者。我是大卫·麦克拉尔斯。前中央情报局分析师转行间谍小说家。我们一起是另一个Goalhanger节目《Rest is Classified》的主持人，我们为您带来来自秘密和间谍世界的最佳故事。
It's right, Gordon, and our new six-part series tells the story of John F. Kennedy, the CIA, and Cuba. It's a covert war of botched invasions, mafia deals, and CIA plots to kill Fidel Castro. The CIA has a secret army, the mob has a vendetta, and Kennedy is caught in the middle So what if the answer to the 20th century's most infamous assassination is found not on the streets of Dallas, but 90 miles off the coast of Florida? And for our declassified club members, oh, you're in for a treat because we've gone even further. They have an exclusive three-part miniseries that digs deep into these conspiracies. We've also got as part of that a jaw-dropping episode with Anthony Scaramucci, the Mooch himself,
没错，戈登，我们的新六集系列讲述了约翰·F·肯尼迪、中央情报局和古巴的故事。这是一场由拙劣的入侵、黑手党交易和中央情报局暗杀菲德尔·卡斯特罗的阴谋组成的秘密战争。中央情报局有一支秘密军队，黑帮有宿怨，而肯尼迪夹在中间。那么，如果20世纪最臭名昭著的暗杀事件的答案不是在达拉斯的街头，而是在离佛罗里达海岸90英里的地方呢？对于我们的解密俱乐部会员，哦，你们有福了，因为我们走得更远。他们有一个独家的三集迷你剧，深入挖掘这些阴谋。我们还有一集令人瞠目结舌的节目，嘉宾是安东尼·斯卡拉穆奇，那个“Mooch”本人，
who says he has insider evidence that ties the mob directly to live. Lee Harvey Oswald. All this sounds good to you. We can listen to the rest is classified wherever you get your podcast. If you think you know who killed JFK, think again. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他说他有内部证据将黑帮直接与李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德联系起来。所有这些听起来对你来说不错。我们可以在你获取播客的任何地方收听《Rest is Classified》。如果你认为你知道是谁杀了肯尼迪，再想想吧。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。